[Music]
the romance Johnny blood-clot back on
the podcast for his 2,000th appearance
on the show aka giant underdog
that's right giant onto das good to see
you man thank you man thanks for having
me we had a great conversation we talked
about his experience doing Joe Rogan
show we talked about his life as a Hari
Krishna monk we talked about the new
documentary he's working on 30 to life
34 light 30 30 30 to life with Paul de
Gelder and Kip Anderson and his brand
new book called PMA effect awesome
episode what did you think it was epic
you know I try to learn something to
pick your brain and I was all him and I
you know I always have my just wind you
up man
you know you know what buttons to push
me alright man so you guys enjoyed this
can I say peace implants I always do
that do a peace implants man chai Ananda
das Cheyenne indeed I'm the house dude
to back for round 25 I don't know how
many times you've done this but good to
see you again my friend absolutely
delighted to have you back here we
should quickly say I don't want to
linger on this but we did record a
podcast like two weeks ago and it was
epic it was like over an hour and a half
and I looked over at my digital audio
recorder and realized that at some point
it it had cut out and we did it's the
only mechanical failure that I actually
only want in 400 episodes it's only
happened one other time so there's a
reason that special is bringing us
together and it is we're back again and
it tested the the boundaries of my PMA
my brother because I definitely got up
in my head about it I was like I can't
believe this is happening and you're
like dude I was an obstacle actually we
were just talking and everything that we
were talking about manifested that when
you know things happen you got to be
able to push through it and see that
it's at
since Annette and then next thing we
know I look over your sweat and you got
your classic attack I thought it was
like holy [ __ ] what's going on and then
you're like none of this recorded yeah I
know it was rough yeah and here's the
thing like adaptability is what it's
about it's not about like oh man you
know shaming myself because I had a
strong reaction because I was
emotionally invested in our conversation
and excited about the prospect of
sharing it and then it goes sideways it
goes left the expectation is not met and
that doesn't mean that you're not going
to be disappointed but what I've noticed
is the half-life of that disappointment
fading much more quickly so I can like
rough it off like a little bit easier
than perhaps I used to be able to well
you know what it is - it's and doing
this documentary and that I'm doing 30
to life and working with these parolees
that have done insane amounts of time is
that you can't keep punishing yourself
when things happen and you know it was
the same thing yeah well it's a little
embarrassing to compare like our
conversation didn't record - a guy who's
you know coming off 25 years you know
the thing was you always have to look
ahead and try to make a positive and
look to the positive and immediately
when that happened I was like yo chill
it's cool we're gonna go ready to have
your anniversary dinner and you know
it's you know things happen but it's
always like we were talking about that
even in my races and I've never had a
race where yeah every it's been a
running joke yeah between us cuz I'm
like every time you do an Ironman
something goes crazy sideways on you
you've never done an Ironman race where
you showed up and it just went to plan
nope what's going on with that is the
test of tests because not only do you
have to complete the endurance test it's
a mental test too you know two things
are gonna happen and it's like you
always have to be resilient resilience
ease is
quality that I've had to develop in my
life to push through them through
anything that [ __ ] man well speaking of
things that are happening right now
yesterday you were on Joe Rogan's
podcast that was a big moment yes so I
wanted to kind of recap it for a minute
I mean it was cool I thought you crushed
it I'll let you rocked it I thought you
guys had a really amazing conversation
that I think goes a long way towards
bridging this gap between the vegan
plant-based community and other
perspectives on diet and nutrition and
you know I really like the way that Joe
opened it up by saying look there's a
toxic dialogue happening right now
whether you're paleo or carnivore or
low-carb or whatever it is we're all in
our respective silos we're shouting at
each other on social media and we're
missing the big picture which is that
most people out there are just suffering
they're eating McDonald's they're not
taking care of themselves they're over
medicated they're in jobs they hate and
all of that bickering basically just
perpetuates a status quo that's in
nobody's interest and the fact that Joe
had the grace to have someone like
yourself on the show who's coming from a
different perspective I think speaks
very highly of his character and his
genuineness when it comes to really
trying to find a better way to
communicate and I think this breakdown
in productive dialogue is something you
know obviously we're not just seeing it
in the debates around health and
nutrition it's it's you know infected
our political discourse and basically
every other kind of productive
conversation that we're trying to have
is being poisoned right now by sectors
and the population and that's what yeah
and we're divided and you said it during
the podcast like we're supposed to be
the United States of America and we're
the divided States of America right now
it's so [ __ ] toxic and there's so
much disrespect and so much [ __ ] going
back and forth with the social media
stuff like I just want to sit down and
have
conversation about the whole thing and
be respectful obviously I don't agree
with a lot of the things that he does
but you know I have friends that do the
same things and I don't I don't hate on
them but the fact of the matter is it's
bridging a gap and it was the olive
branch that was extended to come on and
have a conversation I think I personally
think if the [ __ ] went epic man we've
done good if we went and talked about so
much different [ __ ] and had a good time
and had laughs I mean you know when he
got into the whole you know cholesterol
and saturated fat I was like well you
know who's funding those studies like
there was certain things I had to be
like well I think you have to pick your
battles yeah and look at the bigger
picture of what are you trying to
accomplish in this conversation like you
could have dug in and gone into the
trenches on a specific sort of point
that I was trying to make and I think
ultimately you making the decision to
like look let's just make this about
inspiration and goodwill that's what I
could quibble about these little things
but I think that would have just gone
off the rails and and and I think it
would have undermined the greater you
know impact that you can have by saying
look this is where I'm coming from and
and having people leave that experience
with perhaps a different perspective on
a lifestyle that you've been leading for
you know what 30 years at this point I
mean and really shift people's prepend
on the lifestyle because you're coming
from a very unique perspective I mean so
many people commented that were like you
know yeah you know it's just one kind
like just you get all the trolls on
social and a lot of it was coming you
know this these vegans were like after
listening to that [ __ ] I don't even know
where you stand on hunting that was
[ __ ] you had a change on attacked by
vegans yeah I didn't you I don't pay
attention anything no I know but it was
like I you know I saw it cuz it came up
and I was you know tagged it do I give
it there they're basically perpetuating
the very thing that you were trying to
speak exactly and you know what most of
the people were like that [ __ ] was
epic like [ __ ] 99% of the people that
heard the podcast all the way through
and you know it was it was it was a it
was a great conversation yeah well whose
hilarious is it was clear very early on
like Joe makes this decision to just
kind of you know throw you a little bone
and then like lean back and you just you
were like a wind-up doll which well
basically like you would just go like
he'd ask you one question and then you'd
go for like 25 minutes yeah well he
could have interjected but he's like I'm
just gonna let this guy tell his story
you're on fire one of the things that I
really wanted to get across was the fact
that I'm gonna limit myself he was like
you know vegan and I was like I don't
call myself a vegan let's talk about
that I mean yeah you're like look I'm
more of a bhakti yoga guy cuz that's
your entry point into all of this yeah
because I was like I don't call myself a
vegan I don't call myself I don't label
myself a higher man I don't label myself
a punk rocker
I don't put mundane labels on to my and
somebody just asked me that because like
before I even went on the podcast I was
like I don't call myself a vegan and
they're like why not and I'm like
because that limit show was like yeah
but you are right yeah I said I practice
all the ethics of veganism to the unti
degree which is I don't use animal
products I don't wear animal products I
don't support any testing and I don't
eat any any animal products whatsoever
but I'm coming from a more universal
approach with everything that I do which
I said I call myself a higher Kushner
before I call myself anything he's like
what like it was you know I kind of
threw him sideways on the whole thing
like to me to defend my vegan position
and I was like well dude here check rice
out he's like where did where did the
Hari Krishna thing come in and then you
told like a 40-minute story yeah to
bring that around yeah and it was good
because you had to contextualize that in
order for it to make sense yeah
otherwise it's like yellow juice dudes
we got it let people don't know really
what Hari Krishna's about and well I
kind of tried I had to you know to break
it down and
say like yo it was Bad Brains and they
got me the job at a health food store
and then the guy there was this famous
punk rocker named who played in this
band of dots and then he was you know I
would challenge him every day
philosophically like and he would defeat
me by quoting baccarat Tom and
bhagavad-gita and like all of their
stuff and giving me this book science of
self-realization that [ __ ] was once I
read that book and actually wait a
minute to correct myself he did not give
me that book he said to me Krishna is
going to show you that what I'm telling
you is the truth
in two days later I took organic vegan
groceries to my mom and I'm in 74th
Street in Jackson Heights Roosevelt's
train station and there's a Hari Krishna
there and that's who gave me the science
of self-realization two days later and
then I'm like you're not gonna [ __ ]
believe this dude I'll go back to the
helpful story and he just laughed he had
like the shaved head with the pot little
patches yeah yeah what do they call that
Sika Sika yes there's some robes in the
whole thing it's a it was he was a monk
and he was distributing books in a train
station and the thing was that's where I
learned about service because he goes I
said well you should just give me that
book why should I have to pay for the
knowledge and he goes it's about you
surrendering to the process and that's
why I said well I don't have any money
all I have is these groceries he's like
well I've been working here all day how
about I I take one of those bottles of
juice and I said yeah that's a good
trade I'll trade you the bottle of juice
for the book and then I read that book
and I was like I gotta go to the temple
maybe that's what brought you in so the
Hari Krishna thing is fascinating and I
want to kind of explore this a little
bit more deeply I recently had Nima
Delgado on the podcast by time this airs
that will have already aired but
everybody knows him as the crazy you
know fit vegan bodybuilder guy that got
like rocks of physique like nobody's
business it's insane he's never eaten
meat in his whole life but what I did
not know about him was his crazy
spiritual story he grew up with Hari
Krishna parents
and he is an adherent to the principles
to this deserve ventured away and now he
seems like he's kind of back in that
world and interesting in an interesting
way and what's compelling about that is
he obviously doesn't doesn't you know
sort of cut the picture of what you
would expect of a person who is of that
perspective in faith and and I think you
know from my own personal perspective
when I think of Hari Krishna I think of
you know the people the the monks
ringing the bells and and you know
trying to get you to buy the book in the
airport or the bus station or walking
through the park in some urban center
and looking at it like well that's weird
that's clearly some kind of weird cult
and that's about all I knew about and
right you know that's that that is the
be-all end-all of my education when it
comes to Hari Krishna just some weird
fringe like religious cult so it walked
me through and explained to me why you
found this compelling and and maybe
what's you know the truth behind it that
resonates with you versus kind of that
image that I have in my head right so to
break it all down I would reference my
guru Sri Laprade and a film that came
out about his life called you ever
well-wisher and he comes from a
sampradaya in India that goes back
thousands and thousands of years of
unbroken teachers a son per daya is
Alinea at the sibling succession
parampara disciplic succession
so his spiritual master his guru bhakti
siddhanta said you have to go to the
west and spread this knowledge now
proper at 70 years old he was already in
retired life sannyasi so for him to get
on a ship and cross two oceans and have
a heart attack two heart attacks and
come to New York because his guru told
him to take the knowledge of the Vedas
where is all yoga stems from the Veda
means knowledge
so at seven years old he comes to New
York he gets robbed he's
you know just his life was about service
so you know down on the lower Eastside
opens up a storefront all the Yippies
and hippies and Allen Ginsberg and
everybody and he starts the printing of
his books so bhagavad-gita as it is
srimad-bhagavatam all this so this is
back in in in the 60s and back way and
he came to New York in the seventies oh
no he came to new you I believe it was
66 uh-huh and he passed him like 70 77
yeah so you know where he came to was
the neighborhood where I live and grew
up basically which was a very dangerous
area for him to be down there but that's
the work while all the other gurus were
living up on Park Avenue that's why I
think he resonated with a lot of people
and especially with me when I found out
about his story because he came here
with $7 in a case of books can you
imagine at 70 at 70 years old $7 in a
case of books and the order of his guru
and having faith in that order that his
guru told him this was already pre
ordained that this is going to happen
this is there's a golden period you know
whatever the Age of Aquarius everyone's
looking for spiritual knowledge just go
everything will happen and it did people
started joining the temples got built
and hit the books the books went out so
when you see people in the robes and the
shaved head those are the monks so their
job is to go out there and follow in the
footsteps of the acharya acharya means
one who leads by example and that's what
prophet did and distribute those books
to help the next person in line so
coming from where i came from which was
a life of violence and a life a crime
and a life for drugs and just all the
insanity that me and my brothers had to
go through and still you know when i
first met the devotees in 1980 i
actually met them first in washington DC
hanging out as a punk-rocker and we used
to like make fun of them dancing and all
the punk rockers we would just spoof on
them dancing around on the street you
know like punk rockers with the Hari
Krishna's right but then somebody tried
to get you know we would see them all
the time and they would be so nice and
then some jerk-offs tried to like get in
their face and and I said and I just got
up in the dudes face I was like yell
back to [ __ ] off dude don't don't do
nothing to these people I'm gonna
[ __ ] smash you they're not bothering
you [ __ ] off and that was before now
before I got to New York but see that
was and when I found out later it's all
about in a weird way that was doing some
devotional service it was like you know
it was planting a seed I'm hearing the
mantra they gave me the food they like
and then even with the Bad Brains when I
was meeting them down in DC they I was I
was in this health food store called
fields of Plenty and the guy would go to
the temple every day and go get the food
and then bring it back and I would like
steal some of his food and after work
and half for like two months the guy
goes yo you know I know you stole my
food every day I was like what I did mad
man cuz I you know and he's like yeah
but it's okay it's spiritual food you're
supposed to steal it there's no hard and
fast rules so is everything legal had to
be the first time anybody had said
anything like that to you know how cus I
was oh yeah you know I had he brought
you to the temple for the first time
yeah well I went to the temple the first
time when I got back to New York and
then the Bad Brains got me a job at a
health food store and then all of that
stuff just happened it just kept
happening and happening and it was like
then when I read the book and knew
understood the philosophy of what it is
bhakti-yoga it's about service to other
people it's about helping other people
you know spreading you know the wisdom
and stuff like that and renunciation and
all this amazing stuff because you know
it says that you know religion without
philosophy is fanaticism
and that's what you have today is a lot
of fanatics and then you know philosophy
without religion or devotion it is
mental concoction you need a combination
of both so when I read those books by
property the bhagavad-gita as it is the
Isha pond Ishod the bhagavatam all these
little other books science and
self-realization which was snippets of
his lectures to people on certain topics
I was like you know and the main chapter
that hit me was like spiritual solutions
to material problems because everyone's
trying to fix a material problem with
another material answer it don't work
what really starts healing people and I
needed healing because everything that I
had gone through lock up and the drugs
and everything else I needed to do some
deep healing and punk rock wasn't doing
it nothing was doing it it's only when I
came in contact with Bad Brains and then
that led me to the health food store and
then I started going to yoga and then I
started going to the temple and
everything and reading the books and
applying it because you know it's not
just about being armchair philosophers
that's one of the things Prabha said was
that you don't just read this book and
then okay I have this knowledge and I'm
above you and I feel superior to you
it's not about that it's about taking
that knowledge and applying it to your
life not being an armchair philosopher
and staying humble humility she not a
piece in a chain uh Toto avulsion or not
you should always think of yourself
lower than a straw in the street devoid
of all sense of false prestige and
always ready to offer respects and
service to others that's the mood that
you're trying to cultivate as a devotee
and it just resonated so much with me
because you would go to the temple they
would just make you feel so special they
would serve you hand and foot and sit
down with you and talk philosophy and I
came at a very challenging I was trying
to defeat it because I thought I was mr.
philosopher because I read Gorge Eve
Krishnamurti all these books and I
couldn't defeat it what's interesting to
me is is your openness and reach
tivity - this like the fact that you
have this thirst for knowledge this
thirst for growth and expansion and you
know I've heard you talk about you know
kind of the you know the process that
led you to that like meeting the Bad
Brains and the impact that HR had on you
and you know changing your relationship
with food and all of these little kind
of Domino's but I'm not sure I totally
understand what it was that actually
catalyzed this shift from you know sort
of you know Street cretan type character
to somebody who really like wanted to
improve their live their life you know
like that that's thirst like it's one
thing to go okay I know I need to get my
[ __ ] together and kind of grudgingly
drag yourself through some process of
like you know you know cleaning house
but that's very different from you know
a spiritual awakening where you're like
let me read that book I can't wait to go
see what Krishnamurti has to say like
where did that enthusiasm come from
because that's that's self-generated I
think it came from the fact that I
started seeing how it was making me feel
to meditate and making me feel how to do
when I was doing yoga and then how I
felt when I went to the temple enchanted
and and got up and chanted japa
meditation the Hari Krishna maha-mantra
on beads it wasn't anything that had to
do with something I can explain mentally
it was going beyond the mind beyond you
know spiritual education and spiritual
knowledge is something you have to live
in experience and that's what and I tell
this story in a new book I wrote and the
Kris Carver the tattoo artist his he
told this story he said oh yeah his
mother and father went to Korea and his
mother was involved with these Buddhists
that meditated and they you know his
father's like an old-school type dude
and took his father there
they tried to get the father to meditate
and Chris Garvey's father said why
should I meditate and the monk said try
it for 30 days and see how you feel
after 30 days and he did and he and I
just had dinner with Chris the other
night his father still meditating so I
used the analogy all the time that it's
not enough to really taste the nectar
and and and you know that's inside the
jar you have to open the jar it's not
something that you can continuously
mentally speculate about mmm you have to
actually apply yourself to the science
the formula and then get the result and
the result that I got to see through
spiritual practice was what it was
freeing me from my anxiety which you
know the material world is full of that
I was a wall I had [ __ ] I was hunted
as a fugitive but I had people looking
for me it was all this stuff going on
and still doing the drugs and still
doing whatever and it was how I felt how
meditation and practice and getting up
early in the morning and and and and and
going and doing service and all this
stuff it's how it made me feel and freed
me from all of those demons of my past
so if I'm gonna say you know how did the
process work it was because I did the
work right you did the work the practice
thing is such a obvious but but really
underappreciated and overlooked aspect
of this whole thing I mean you know your
look as somebody who travels all the
time you're in airports what do you see
when you walk into the airport bookstore
there's like 8,000 self-help books right
every month like you know 20 more new
self-help books and like if these worked
then there would be no need for more
self-help books and I think what happens
is and I'm not besmirching self-help
books they're well-intentioned and I'm
sure most of them have good information
in them
but I think what happens is people are
in pain they reach out to these books
they read them and they can
intellectually understand what they're
saying but there's a gap between that
and actually putting whatever wisdom is
packed into whatever book into a
practice that is replicable and
sustainable and daily right well that's
one of the things that I say in the new
book that I wrote on the PMA effect
they're one of the first things I say is
you have to agree with me right now to
do the things daily that are listed in
the book it's not enough to just
understand them and grasp them
intellectually you have to actually do
the work and apply yourself for the
change to work for I just know what I
just tried to put in the book what
worked for me and what worked for me was
taking action when I got into this I was
like I got I want to live as a monk I
want to live this because I started
getting no buddy can sustain life
without pleasure it's you're either
gonna look for pleasure in the material
world which ultimately because most
pleasures in the mode of passion so it's
pleasure in the beginning and misery in
the end only pleasure in the mode of
goodness is pleasure and be in the
beginning and the end and then beyond
that is spiritual pleasure so in order
to really experience that you get those
little tastes it's called rasa which is
taste yeah it's gonna be there and
you're gonna get that taste but in all
what I saw was how it made me feel and
then I'm like I want to do this more how
do I do this how do I I said right away
how do I I want to become a monk I want
to become a monk and I want to live this
every day and reap the effects in my
life of what this process could do and I
would see the other devotees and be like
man these people are so happy and I
think that's the greatest thing that
everyone sees Hari Krishna's dancing and
they're so ecstatic and they're like oh
that [ __ ] brainwash because everybody
that's walking around makes a point
about the
if you look at people's they say the
faces and index of the mind so if you
look around and you look at people on
the street nobody's [ __ ] happy and
here's these people they have nothing
and they're dancing around and they're
happy and joyous and it's because yo
they've devoted their life to this path
and and there's so much power in that
mantra that it just it brings happiness
and I know that from experience because
I would do my two hours of Chapa
meditation I would go and do the
congregational chanting with the drums
and everything and how it made me feel
was something I never experienced in a
material world before that's why I took
to the process it was a feeling that I
experienced it wasn't you know mental
mental you know intellectual
understanding something intellectually
or mentally does not sustain that's why
people read self-help books and they
have the knowledge but then you talk to
them six months later their to go in and
do something else I didn't want to be
like that I wanted to be like alright
I'm gonna take this up prop I said do
this and you'll see the results that
come and that's what I did and that's
why I took to it because little by
little the path was leading to me
completely surrendering and becoming a
brahmacari a celibate monk which I did
for two years right which I want to talk
about do you have your chopped up with
you right now your bag do you take that
everywhere you go what's that what's the
daily meditation process look like I try
to get as many rounds as I can there's a
hundred and eight beads on so you chant
Hari Krishna Krishna Krishna Krishna
honey on deity Romani Rama Rama Rama
hottie hottie on each bead and then you
do it around the japa mala it's a
hundred and eight and then you're
supposed to do that sixteen rounds do I
do that every day not every day I can
when I'm on the road traveling with the
band I say my mantras every day because
we have long drives or whatever and I
have the Nash ringa Kivar champlain
which is the ultimate prayer for
protection but there's so much craziness
going on in the world
that's like my coat of armor that when I
chant it takes you out of the modes of
material nature the three modes are
ignorant passion and goodness and it's a
spiritual sound vibration so it puts you
in touch with the spiritual connection
and the spiritual energy and I just it's
not something you can really explain I
try to tell be experiential it's it is I
say yo get some beads and I'll show you
the mantra and chant it yourself and I
know the 108 has significance and Hindu
culture I just forget what it do you
know do you know why it's 108 I'm not
like I don't know geology I think it's a
big thing yes it's an auspicious number
you know Krishna it's a bunch of
different reasons which I can't put my
right but on that on the protective
armor thing you know this crazy story
right when you were in it you were you
were traveling with the band and a van
you guys got in an accident like the
family yeah it was crazy because like
you know we were on tour and it was in
the 90s and you know the ultimate test
is they say yo will you take will you
chant at the time of death that's the
ultimate thing everyone is born death is
certain so death is the big test
we have little exams during our life but
then when death comes can you focus and
meditate at the time of death and
remember Krishna and chant the holy name
so we were like playing up it was the
wintertime when we played in Vermont and
we were driving home through the
mountains and I told the dude I said
look man stay on the highway man and you
know I know that he smoked [ __ ] hash
too and I was like don't smoke and stay
on the [ __ ] highway because it on
like black ice and yeah it was it was it
was [ __ ] it was it started to snow
and get bad and I my dude and I'm
sleeping in the front chair and I'm
sitting in the front passenger seat of
the van and I wake up to hearing oh my
god what going off the cliff that's what
I woke up to in the middle of the night
and then the
van just started the van was just just
went off the road we hit black ice the
guy was smoking [ __ ] hash and he went
on a side road to save 30 minutes of
time or whatever he thought he was
saving and we went off the road and the
van just flipped and bounced and flipped
and bounced and the whole time I was
just chanting hi Christian at the top of
my lungs everybody else was screaming
and I just was like you know I just
chanted as loud as I could so at that
point it's like a it's so deeply
engrained in you as like a go-to thing
for dealing with stress well you know
I've talked to a lot of people and found
that this to be true if you talk to a
lot of people have near-death experience
the mind it's so painful at the time of
death that the mind is racing to find
what it felt more comfortable the most
comfortable within its life for some
people that's going to be family or you
know greedy people it's their bank
account oh my god I'm losing everything
or so if you practice spiritually every
single day at a time of death what are
you going to take shelter of I took
shelter of Krishna and I was chanting
and it was just crazy man because like
the one dude got thrown out of the back
window and was laying on the highway
when we fought cuz the van first flipped
he was going so fast he was the cops
that he was doing 80 miles an hour so
when the van first flipped it like one
dude got thrown or right when we started
going over and flipped the first time he
got thrown out the back window like all
the gear was in the van so it was on top
of everybody and my face was all bloody
the bolts in the front seat snapped and
like slam my face off the [ __ ]
windshield I was cut up I ran back up
onto the road and it was like kind of
like a bad comedy coz just as I got to
the top of the road the salt truck went
by [ __ ] of head and then I can see that
there was a construction night crew down
on the road
like probably a 3/4 of a mile down the
road it was all lit up so I ran down
there to tell them but the interesting
thing was as I got to the top of the
road and I walked probably 20 feet had
we gone off that road 20 feet later the
drop was over 300 feet we would have
[ __ ] died and I was like yo and I was
just chanting and thankful and I ran all
the way down there and [ __ ] said hey
man we got in an accident we went off
the [ __ ] Road people are hurt and
they called Kyle hurt were people well
they have broken bones and [ __ ] like
that like but uh and you were fined yeah
man I had cut someone fake forehead and
[ __ ] and whatever the [ __ ] and my nose
got [ __ ] up but compared to what the
[ __ ] I could have happened but I really
feel you know for whatever reason that
was just and I've been tested like that
certain times which crazy shits happened
and like all of a sudden out of nowhere
cuz death can come at any moment and
it's like you hope that you have enough
preparation time to say you know say
your mantras and and take shelter of
what you got to take shelter but it's a
test and that's why I try to chant every
day and and you know trying to try to
live a positive life every day because I
think we attract the energy that we put
out into the world to like you know and
even then I was like having parties and
[ __ ] making pot brownies and being a
[ __ ] jerk and I kind of think that
that was like hey man slap right I saved
you from 20 feet of dying yeah you would
have went off a cliff but wake the [ __ ]
up man human life is very valuable and
you're pissing it away and the thing is
when you do things in knowledge of what
you're supposed to be doing as opposed
to not knowing any better the karmic
reaction of that is much more severe you
know so I I took that as a
as as as a blessing as a calling as a
call to action to take it to the next
level absolutely and and how long were
you in this before you became a monk and
you were a monk for like two years right
yeah and how much of that was in Hawaii
well it first started out in Puerto Rico
and when I got to Puerto Rico like I was
doing the raw food thing you know I was
see yeah like if I look if I glanced at
the recorder it's just ironic so it's
not recording I'm listening to you
though so I know but what was really
weird was but when I joined the temple
see I first got into the whole thing I
went full bore raw foods I met
Victoria's convinced cos I like met the
people from Epocrates Health Center this
dude I knew Kevin had a raw food
restaurant so I got in I was completely
raw organic organic vegan so when I went
my friend Vinnie that talked to me the
drummer from the dots and now that
unsane he told me he lived in Puerto
Rico in the temple you're in the [ __ ]
mountains and it's [ __ ] beautiful you
look across the valley you're in Gobbo
and then he'll jump gays right there
it's like so magical and mystical I was
like I want to join that temple he's
like just go down man they'll accept you
in so I didn't call ahead nuttin and you
showed up I showed up with we each had
three 2500 how did you get to Puerto
Rico when you're kind of on the land
they didn't check ID you were able to
get on planes without [ __ ] Puerto
Rico's part of the United States so I
didn't even I had like a fake ID so like
you don't need a passport you know and
these [ __ ] to go to Puerto Rico and I
flew down and I had 325 pound bags of
sprouting seeds and this other guy Tomas
from the punk rock scene he had 20
because he was 2 on this journey with me
we went down there together he had bags
of sprouting seeds we showed up to the
temple with no possessions other than
sprouting seeds they're like what the
[ __ ] is this I was like yo those are
sprouting seeds and right away from the
like the vibe that I realized
something's [ __ ] going on here
something's they like well I doubt
you're even gonna get to use those like
and then it was just this weird vibe and
I just remember like the first so they
said okay hey you sleep in this you know
you sleep in this that the dorms and
[ __ ] and it was up in up native
rainforest so like the first night we
[ __ ] got like I was like y'all is
there any more mosquito and that's they
like nah no but we don't have any extra
mosquito nets so I had like [ __ ] you
know 300 mosquito bites and then at 4
o'clock in the morning I hear animals
screaming and it turns out there's a pig
slaughterhouse across the road and
they're killing the [ __ ] animals I'm
like so the dream and this tropical
fantasy of being in this beautiful
temple in the rainforest and everything
started becoming a [ __ ] nightmare and
I'm like wow man this is and I just
wanted to surrender and be a devotee and
then the temple president this guy of a
crash total [ __ ] criminal calls me
into the office and I'm thinking he's
gonna welcome me and me and my friend
sit down and he's like who the hell told
you to come to this temple I'm like what
he's like who told you to come to this
temple I said well my friend lived here
Vinnie and you know he said it's it's a
great temple I just wanted to surrender
he's like [ __ ] I'm gonna find out
what you're doing here and I'm gonna get
to the bottom of this and then I'm gonna
throw you the [ __ ] out and I'm like dude
how are you coming at me like that I'm
you know I'm trying to be a devotee I'm
trying to surrender he's like what's
with all those [ __ ] seeds you got
like he's cursing at me very aggressive
he thought they were drugs no he just
was like that's [ __ ] when nobody
wants that [ __ ] and you know this and
that and then so the first morning they
always give a class on the bog of the
time and his whole class he's sitting on
an elevated seat looking at us and he's
like if you don't like it here you get
the hell out on that road and you just
we're not even giving you a ride back to
the air it started feeling like some
Jim Jones type [ __ ] like what the [ __ ]
did we step into over here and then I'm
like yo I'm a raw foodist like you know
can we get some fruit and vegetables and
he's like we have no fruit and veg I'm
like there's the trap like he's like
throw more chillies into the milk you
know hugging type you know stuff
basically it's it's you know interject
imbalanced human into you know a
spiritual organization and like light a
match and and then we just he made us
work all day long in the hot Sun no hats
no nothing on on a cliff come on dude
where's your gratitude
removing tree stumps with an axe
I was like yo there's a cat there's a
bull he's like you're not using the bull
this is building character get out there
and you know we had to chop around the
whole thing and then pull the tree
stumps out on this hill and it was just
after like three days we were fried I
was like go let's just get the [ __ ] out
of here and that's and that's what we
did and then it turned out he was raping
women in the temple he was he was
[ __ ] smuggling drugs he was doing all
this crazy [ __ ] he was like [ __ ] a
total gangsta live you know and that's
the same guy he was the vice president
of the Brooklyn temple and later on
asked me to sell sell drugs for him and
do all this crazy [ __ ] it's not the guy
who threatened you yeah yeah so what
happened was I had left the temple III
ended up joining it in Hawaii and then I
came back after a year in Hawaii I came
to New York and did you do the whole
thing with the crazy hair and the yeah I
wore the robes I went out and chanted I
whipped pictures of you from that time
you know I mean I'm sure there's some
somewhere but I don't have any right
right and then I left Hawaii and I came
to New York how long were you in Hawaii
a year yeah
and that was and I was where it clicked
in and that's when you started also
doing martial arts and vos Karate Kid
well it was
they had me first on a big island up on
the farm and stuff like that and this
one devotee practiced martial arts and
then and then we we came back to the to
the wahoo temple and he would train you
know train every day so we would go I
would get up at 2 o'clock every morning
chant all my rounds two hours before
Mongol arty which is the it's the
morning ceremony and then I would do
that I will go to class and then before
breakfast I would train run or swim or
do Coty's or whatever and then eat
breakfast and then go out to Kalakaua
Avenue and distribute books and do
whatever so that lasted about a year and
I started noticing now in retrospect
that weird [ __ ] was going on out there -
it was like you didn't know about it but
then when you heard about it you're like
oh [ __ ] that's what the [ __ ] was going
on there and this whole institution
ultimately kind of collapses upon itself
write this like this this sort of
poisoning of the you know the ideas of
probable and the kind of fundamental
travelpod ever appointed any of them to
become they took it upon themselves to
be his successor when he left the planet
in 77 so I went back to New York and
that's when I did I was the biggest one
of the biggest hustler collectors in the
entire movement got happy on some
stories doing doing stickers at concerts
and [ __ ] just crazy [ __ ] dude Sant
wheelchair Santa and [ __ ] just you
know crazy stuff to make insane amounts
of money like I was collecting like
three thousand four thousand dollars a
week and turning it over and then I
started hearing that day
stealing the money and all this shit's
going on and Prabhupada never appointed
any of them to be guru they did it
themselves and you just started hearing
all these nightmares these people kids
were getting raped and all of this [ __ ]
was going on and I'm like once you know
I heard about the kids and in the school
get raped that's when I was like yo I'm
[ __ ] I'm I'm going against these
people now and I let I left the temple
to do music and stuff whatever like that
but I never lost faith I kept going to
the temple so then one of the weekends I
was going back to the temple for the
Sunday feast that guy the crash comes up
to me and he's like we get large amounts
of marijuana and cocaine donated do you
know where I could get rid of it and and
we can give the money to the temple I
said dude you're asking me to sell
[ __ ] drugs he's like yeah well you
know the person doesn't want to give
money like they have becomes like a mob
thing yeah so that's what he was doing
and he was stealing money like he did he
had all these businesses and it was just
keeping the money and driving sports
cars and selling guns and doing steroids
he was like good American [ __ ] thug
dude that's what that's what the [ __ ] he
was and then I told this woman I was
like I said yo you know boo crash asked
me to [ __ ] sell drugs for him she's
like what and uh and I said yeah he
[ __ ] said you know do I know where to
get rid of pounds and [ __ ] kilos of
cocaine and [ __ ] and I was like cuz he
knew I was Street you know he knew I'm
from the [ __ ] streets and I didn't
know where to get rid of it but I never
I always kept my material life and I
kept the temple a sanctuary I never
brought any [ __ ] into the temple
when I had material desires to have a
girlfriend or do whatever I left I was
like y'all I can't this is my sanctuary
I'm never going to pollute this
sanctuary if I want to smoke weed or I
want to be with girls or do whatever I'm
not gonna do it in here and fake the
funk and be fake and be a hypocrite I
left these guys did it in the temple
and did whatever the [ __ ] they wanted
and and is that still going on or did it
just well let me let me not get ahead of
that and then I get to what's going on
now so what happened was I came back to
the Sunday feast unbeknownst to me she
went and told everybody that yo
creations selling drugs so he comes up
to me in his Sunday feast he's like I
should beat your [ __ ] ass this is how
he's talking to me I said what he's like
yo you [ __ ] told everybody the
conversation we had I should [ __ ] you up
and I was like yo you're selling drugs I
said let me tell you something bro and I
was only like what 22 whatever the [ __ ]
younger he's a grown-ass man taking
steroids I know he got guns and
everything else and I just said bro I
ain't like these other dudes if you put
your [ __ ] hands on me you better
watch your back for the rest of your
life because I'm gonna put a baseball
bat across your [ __ ] skull I'm not
playing you ain't doing [ __ ] to me so he
let it die out and then like months down
the road it was like four or five months
later he goes because I had started to
impress in the magazines and saying like
y'all these people are [ __ ] up and I
started exposing and I lost every single
friend of mine that was a hard Christian
to turn against me how could you do this
to me you're destroying I'm like I'm not
destroying nothing I'm putting the truth
out there so people don't get [ __ ]
hustled by these charlatans in the garb
of devotees and Prabhupada said demons
will come to this movement dressed as
devotees to destroy the movement from
within and that's who these [ __ ]
people were that's what they were doing
so everybody turned against me and
called me a [ __ ] demon and I went
against Rommel pod who now turned out he
tried to sucker and steal the temple for
58 million dollars and they kicked them
out but they caught what they were
calling me demon and all this [ __ ] for
speaking the truth and they they
ostracize me from the whole community
nobody would talk to me but I knew what
I had to do was right and I've done that
my whole life I don't care if you are
again
me I will stand in the face of a
thousand [ __ ] and speak the
truth that's what I do
so today months he waits by and all I
was doing all this press and exposing
them and I go to the temp when he's like
oh you know hey you know I got I got
these condominiums in Virginia and you
know we need some work done I'll pay you
$100 a day come down there for a couple
of weeks and do work on the condos with
me and I was like really ah man he's
like everything's cool I understand you
know just you know pretend that
everything was cool so I told my friend
googy the drummer from The Misfits who
was also coming around the temple I said
yo he just invited me down to work on
the condominiums he goes bro they're
gonna [ __ ] frag you if you go down
there you're not coming back they're
gonna [ __ ] kill you
these guys don't [ __ ] play they
killed slow John they killed these other
devotees that spoke out against them
they're gonna [ __ ] whack you dude
you're in the press saying all this [ __ ]
exposing them and I was like he goes bro
don't go you're gonna get you're not
coming back if you go and I didn't go
and and then it just kept continuing and
continuing I kept and my friends were
these kids that were that got raped in
the [ __ ] schools they protected him
they covered it up and I just kept
speaking out against him in and even so
now it became this whole big thing in
America so now they hustle and they use
the temples as you know and this is
what's gone on in Brooklyn the guy just
tried to [ __ ] sell the temple for
like and and I have connections
everywhere I know people everywhere a
big-ass real estate person
three years ago goes hey man ain't this
the temple hates does big huge real
estate development deals and he goes uh
isn't it the temple you lived in three
or five schema on the street it's on the
market for four four [ __ ] fifty eight
million dollars the building I'm like
what they're trying to sell the temple
with they kicked all the devotees
and then this one these corrupt dudes at
the top ramaa pod and all these guys
were trying to sell the temple
underneath the devotees nose and and I
started telling people and then it came
out that it's true and they just now the
devotees all stopped it cuz don't get me
wrong
95% of the devotees
it's the hierarchy who put themselves
they created a pyramid scheme where
there they enjoy is in every the
underlings underneath them you know
that's that's exactly right so the
organization still exists they're still
in India like I've been told if you go
to India we're gonna have you killed and
all these she so did you have any
further run-ins with that dude who he
just got out of prison because they
caught him with drugs and guards no but
here's the thing I saw him maybe I don't
know I think it was five or six years
ago and he started trying to spread
rumors about me to the [ __ ] and I was
like I was like yo what the [ __ ] are you
talking all this [ __ ] he's like I didn't
say that and I was like yo I was a kid
when you threatened me
I said let's walk out of this park right
now I'm challenging you let's go I know
right where we could go and I will
[ __ ] beat your ass he's I gonna wanna
do probably what you anyway but here's
the thing like you've been able to
maintain your krishnakant your
connection with the with you know what
for you is the truth of the truth of the
you know the wisdom of the bhagavad-gita
the Vedas and like this information that
was so impactful for you at that time
exactly because I knew it was still the
truth no matter what I don't throw the
baby out with the bathwater so to speak
I knew that there was this corruption
going on but I knew that what Prabhupada
came to teach was the truth the absolute
truth and how he lived his life and
that's the example that I saw service to
others renunciation no bank account with
millions of dollars in it like these
other dudes everything they went against
everything what Prabha taught but that
doesn't mean that what proper taught is
not the truth so I had that mm-hm and I
held on to that tight
and now all the other devotees are
coming around and being like yo man you
[ __ ] was spot-on with everything man
like you know yeah yeah that's um I mean
it's an amazing you know history lesson
on sowing the seeds of destruction of
your own spiritual religious
organization yeah and you know it's not
the first time that's happened it won't
be the last and you know it's part and
parcel of you know human sickness you
know and I think it's it speaks to it's
it's so ironic because it's an
organization of elevated consciousness
and yet you know here here we you're
butting up against you know the lowest
vibration you can imagine material world
then well that's the tragic thing about
humanity and I think when you kind of
you sort of project out or broaden that
aperture and look at you know what we're
seeing right now are we still in the age
of quarrel oh yeah well but what is a
it's a well let me just finish this
thought it'sit's we're not gonna solve
our problems through the next election
cycle or you know adopting the most
optimal diet or whatever it is we are in
a crisis of consciousness right and the
solution lies in elevating our awareness
and our in expanding our conscious
awareness of what is happening on an
individual level on a systemic level
across the board right so you can adopt
you know the ultimate diet whatever that
may be for you but if you're [ __ ]
crazy and you're an [ __ ] and you know
you hate your spouse and you know you're
unproductive at your job that sucks or
whatever like you're not a healthy
person and perhaps there's a lesson in
elevating that awareness right so I
think that's really you know for me when
I speak to you like that's the heart of
of the power in your life experience in
perspective absolutely I mean we are in
the age of quarrel but there is a golden
period for 10,000 years within the age
of quarrel a day kali yuga lasts four
hundred and thirty seven thousand years
we're only five thousand
years into it but we're 500 years into
the golden period of awareness and
consciousness and we're just starting it
and what I'm just from the bhagavad-gita
yeah the bhagavatam Humabon Gautama the
spotless piranha and really I always try
to see the glass as half-full
and be positive and I'm seeing so much
awareness and consciousness that people
that I would have never thought twenty
years ago would be getting into
meditation and plant-based diet and all
this great amazing stuff
spirituality their own path whatever it
is because it's not dogmatic my path
ain't right for the next person I'm
fully aware that but I see a lot of
growth that's happening in the world and
that's really the only thing that's
gonna fix what the [ __ ] is going on no
no political agenda no food diet no
nothing is gonna fix what's going on
it's it's gonna come from each
individual's like you're up you're up to
mr. absolutely percent I have to be and
remain optimistic and work to educate
the people because that's the whole
problem is the lack of access to
knowledge and education because there's
so much Maya illusion being being
broadcasted to people you know just like
Rage Against the Machine one of my
favorite bands is that it's like what
does the Billboard say come and play
come and play forget about the the
movement and the movement to me is the
movement of the revolution of
consciousness so there's so many
distractions in life what I see those as
jewels on the head of the serpent you
may be attracted to the razzle dazzle
but when you get close to that
it's the bite of death man yeah well I
think new media platforms like
podcasting and you know there's so much
amazing information that's now available
it you know there's there's there's too
much information in general we're being
bombarded with so much content that it's
impossible to stay on top of everything
and I think you have to be more
discerning about what you let into your
consciousness and you're aware
yeah and perhaps most people aren't but
a lot of this information is free
it's like podcasts are free you know
anybody dial this up well I guess you
have to have a device right to listen to
it so there's that but I think we're in
an interesting place where we do have
the the ability to cross this
socio-economic divide that I think has
been problematic in recent years that
that has been promoting this message
that these ideas whether it's wellness
diet nutrition plant-based or otherwise
you know meditation mindfulness that
these are luxuries of the well-heeled
these are elitist ideals that's great if
you got a six-figure income you know or
whatever but I'm just trying to get
through the day right I'm working two
jobs all of this sort of thing and I
think what's so powerful about your
example and and how you live your life
and the way that you're of service is
that for you it's all about blowing up
that idea and making these ideas
practices habits accessible to the
people who need it the most
yeah I mean that's my story in a
nutshell too
you know I didn't have the luxury of all
this stuff and I just see that this
whole even the plant-based and vegan
movement it's like you know you go to
these it's like the people that really
need it the most they can't afford $30
$25 to go into VegFest and you know all
this food and all the access to this
stuff and and go even if they could they
probably would it's not where they're
going well you know the whole thing is
is it comes down to the value system
that's they've been subjected to their
whole life what's important and I'm
I'm doing this documentary now and it's
it's really about that whole thing of
when people grow up in their
surroundings and circumstances you can't
remove their surroundings just like what
my surroundings were that led me to get
incarcerated and led me to be a drug
addict and let you know it's it's not
passing the buck ins and not taking
responsibility for my own actions
because I do but it's just you know this
the surroundings and sets of
circumstances that I've encountered with
these individuals that I'm working with
in this documentary which we you know if
we can get into it it's it's
un-fuckin'-believable what's happened to
these people
so you could say hey this guy did such
and such crime and got away for 20 years
and it's nice to categorize that person
and put him on a shelf but let's open
that [ __ ] book up and let's see what
really went down oh wow he was abused
and molested as a child his mother
turned her back on him and didn't care
the father died they put him in a foster
home he was more abused he became very
angry anybody trying to do anything to
him well if you do a forensic analysis
on on every person mm-hmm who becomes a
violent offender you're gonna be able to
identify you know the all the steps all
the things that occurred all the abuse
suffered etcetera that led to creating
that that individual that human being
and we have a penal system that is
becoming more and more privatized with
built-in incentives to you know keep
people more and more people incarcerated
for longer and longer without enough
redress or interest in developing the
rehabilitative side of it that's very
lost in the education it's about
warehousing and what really fired me up
to get involved with this documentary
and reach out to Paul was
Paul de Gelder right what several
factors and the one was I saw this
movement that I've been involved with
since before any of these people
becoming more of an elitist kind of
thing this plant-based movement and the
[ __ ] vegan [ __ ] and whatever the [ __ ]
and not reaching out to the people that
needed the most and the other thing was
I saw the documentary 13th right and
knowing Noah Levine and the work he's
done writing dr. Hong saying going into
the prisons and doing the Buddhist
ministry and reading articles in such a
magazine that said you know burn these
inmates if I had access to this
knowledge I would not be where I am so
all of that little [ __ ] fire under my
ass and I'm like I need to do something
to try to get out there and show these
people that what worked for me can work
for anybody this is the this is you know
it's the blueprint on how to do it and
I'll never forget because I remember
that back in the day I was doing drugs
and drinking and doing all this crazy
[ __ ] and an HR from the brains just said
come out on this 30-day tour you come
out on this 30-day tour and you stay off
the drugs and you meditate you either
take you eat I eat all mine and you're
gonna see in higher tolerance fight
katella's fight silent I'll is fatal
you're gonna see that your life is gonna
change and I was like I went out on the
tour and after 30 days I was like my
[ __ ] life changed so that's where the
concept but also you had somebody who
took an interest in your life man it was
really the first time that somebody had
earth if not the first time one of the
few people who'd ever said like look I
can see something in this guy like I'm
gonna yeah I'm gonna take him under
right I mean how much of it is that and
how much is it the actual practices
right just just the feeling the sense
that there's somebody out there that
even even if it's just on a limited
basis like actually cares enough to like
it's so important man and it's like and
I'm gonna tell you that's where the
title came from 30 to life but
we sat down and myself and Paul when we
first met the 12 parolees that are
involved in this documentary and we sat
in a room and we told them our story and
where we came from and then they started
going around and telling their story and
the one brother
and he was in he was in the worst
prisons man and he did he did hard
[ __ ] time that we can't even
imagine he was in just the worst places
you never want to go and he just broke
down crying because he's like this is
the first time I can't believe somebody
cares about me enough to come in here
and do this and mentor and help us like
this this is you know and it got me
emotional too because and even today I
was working with one of the brothers and
he's he writes lyrics and poetry and I
told him I'm Imus and Dante Ross the
vice president of Warner Brothers
Records he signed all these hip hop
dudes in the 80s he's famous and I told
them he's coming in next week to talk to
you and his writings and poetry it was
just like it was all his pain and
suffering coming out and and it was you
know he just was so unbelievably moved
that where they're mentoring him and
then this other brother John he's 70
years old man and he's like I can't
believe and I seen him in passing
today's I can't believe what y'all is
doing for us man well imagine you know
and I'm sure you can imagine what it
must feel like to to go through life
without any hope that anything is ever
gonna change you know to be and to be
stuck in this cycle of violence and
incarceration after a certain amount of
time and whatever abuse and you know
history gets packed into that like the
mental state that you're walking around
with has to be self-defeating and has to
you know at some point you know be one
of
hopeless this and so to inter enter that
equation and say hey man I'm gonna take
an interest in you like it seems like a
small thing it's so massive you know and
we should we should just say for people
that are listening John and Paul de
Gelder who's been on the podcast if you
haven't listened to my episode with him
you should definitely check that out guy
like he's an inspiration you know beyond
words you're the one who first
introduced me to him guys survived a
bull shark attack he lost its arm he
lost his leg and one of the most
positive dudes you're ever gonna find
believe his life is completely all about
service he just did you know a week on
Shark Week so probably a lot of people
saw him Matt but you're the one who
introduced me to him he came on the show
it was unbelievable and you guys teamed
up with Kip Anderson from what the
health and cowspiracy and you're
creating this documentary where you're
taking these 25 plus 12 or 12 okay
parolees recently-released dude yeah and
they're all living in this place called
it's called Ahmadiyya how many found
image foundation right downtown LA and
you're kind of putting them through this
this bootcamp experience right like a
spiritual boot camp they're going on a
plant-based diet for 30 days we have
meditation workshops training the
training for a 5k Paul de Gelder is
taking them skydiving there's NFL player
I'm just basing on his name right now
has been doing yoga and meditation
workshops with them so it's you know
they've been going to farm sanctuaries
to meet animals we showed them what the
health it's just all this stuff and
these dudes have come so far and we're
only 15 days into it and they're like
it's it's like the [ __ ] light came on
and the older dude is his name is John
man he's so full of [ __ ] wisdom and
his story is insane he was a kid as both
his parents were [ __ ] murdered and
his uncle took him in and he he sold him
into slavery in the fields of [ __ ] of
the Carolinas to work on plantations and
[ __ ] dude he worked seven days a
[ __ ] week 365 days a year
he was exploited bad [ __ ] happened to
him and he has so much [ __ ] knowledge
everything he says he waits and you see
him really think it out and then he
speaks and it's it's epic man it's like
it's been the most and I've been back
and forth from New York cuz I'm dealing
with other stuff too but the time I've
got to spend with these people this
thing is [ __ ] and it's setting a like
the pilot for a program like this for
the rest of the country and I kept
telling these people like yo you guys
are pioneers man people gonna look to
this and be like wow this is the change
that's necessary you have to change
people from within and all I did was
take the process that worked for me and
it was a deep deep deep search inward to
fix the [ __ ] up me and that's what I
even wrote about in the in the PMA
affair I'm not cured I'm still a work in
progress I'm still [ __ ] every day I
told this dude today I said yo just the
other day I knew this dude that kills a
cocaine and I was like [ __ ] it I could
like my mind just do this thought it
[ __ ] washed through my brain real
quick you could take that cocaine
imagine all the freebase thing you could
do with all that cocaine like that
thought actually manifested in my
[ __ ] mind
yeah I mean I get that you know I
entertain crazy thoughts like that all
the time like once an addict always an
addict yeah you know so you have to be
you have to be vigilant you have to be
why they're their blessings though
they're little reminders no they make
you because if you forget where you came
from you're likely to go back if you
don't remember you pass you doomed to
repeat it
right so that's it's just been a
blessing to me to work with these guys
and
and offer them opportunities and they
many of them have dreams to do certain
things and it's just like you know they
don't have access to that knowledge or a
way to get that done and that's what
we're trying to do whether it's chefs
coming in there and saying hey man if
you want to get trainers that are like
yo you could get a NASM certification
and make six figures a year training
people or whatever it is that they want
to do have a dream and go after it and
that's that's kind of what we we've been
instilling in these men you know you
should have you are you still looking
for mentors to go and talk to these sure
yeah I mean just yet you should get
George raveling you know George
traveling I've had him on the podcast
you should you should listen to this
this episode that I did with a legendary
african-american basketball coach like
one of the Great's of all time who has
become this extraordinary mentor to
young people like he's just revered in
the NBA and in college the ball one of
the great all-time guys and he's also
this huge civil rights activist he was
standing when he was a young dude he was
standing right next to Martin Luther
King when he delivered his I have a
dream speech and after the speech Martin
Luther King handed him the paper with
the speech written on it and he has it
he's an incredible music all the guys in
his 70 can we reach out oh yeah I'll
reach out I saw him I saw him recently
being able [ __ ] him bring him in a
second if I'm sure he'd be up for it
tell him man tell him was you know reach
out I'll put him in touch with with Kip
in LA and the producer that would just
[ __ ] be amazing how's the how's the
plant-based diet going over with these
dudes they [ __ ] love it because we
have this chef he's cordon bleu he has
so he came and cooked us dinner on our
anniversary last time you were over here
me he has none believable repeated a
dish twice in the whole [ __ ] time
that he's been cooking now the about
saiva
that guys level like his service
consciousness is off the chart dude he
came down here on his own dime packed up
his car he [ __ ] works he works 14
hours of [ __ ] day now they want to
give him a
job there because he helps clean up the
whole kitchen he works with the chef's
like he was never gonna find a guy like
this he's like an amazing amazing
amazing dude mange and he was a chef
that's how he met Kip he did pop-up
plant-based pop-up things in San
Francisco and Kip went to one of them
and he's like bro you're [ __ ] amazing
cook and then they said we want to do
something with you down the road and Kip
was talking about opening up a
plant-based pizzeria and then he called
Jay and and Jay thought he's like I got
this project and he's like what the
pizzeria like no I'm doing this film I
want you to come down and it manifests
it out of there but the guy's so humble
and his service attitude is just I mean
I'm just looking at the guy and I'm like
why man you're [ __ ] you're the real
deal you're the real [ __ ] deal you
have compassion
now the other inmates who are over
parole - they're not inmates they're
parolees des seeing the food and they're
like yo man yo vegan power they [ __ ]
connect crazy
can I get I want to get plates to that
stuff so now he's having to cook for he
makes extra food for the other guys who
want it now cuz they seeing the films
and it's there something about as sort
of you know out there as it may sound
and I know you're on the same page with
me on this you're taking these people
who have lived a life of violence you're
removing the violence from their life in
a very practical material way but by
eliminating the violence on their plate
there is a spiritual impact to that
hundred percent and there's a lot of
people who will call [ __ ] on that
and that's like you know
woowoo or whatever but I had that at my
you know I didn't come into this to live
some holier-than-thou lifestyle or or to
save the animals that was not my
perspective but I have found in the 11
years that I've been doing this that
I have grown into a you know a
perspective of him so that kind of
surprised me you know and I think there
is something about you know cleansing
your life of not just practices and
foods and things like that there's a
there's a there's a there's a cleansing
aspect to that and so my question really
is like is that something that you can
see evident and the like how long have
these guys been doing this 15 days yeah
it's only it's been two weeks yeah and
and David get first of all they get in
their blood work back and one of the
guys who was one of the guys is in
remission of cans he has cancer and his
and the other guys you know they've been
eating prison food man it's the worst
[ __ ] you could ever imagine
they have all kinds of health problems
and now the dude told me today he's like
the doctor is like yo you know in it was
saying like your your health and
everything is turning around like we're
seeing because they're doing blood work
on the guys so not only is the health
turning around they're grasping the
message because that's the first thing I
said I learned it from Rastafarians and
Rastafari literally means Prince of
Peace so when I first was told about
this thing it was like we don't have the
right to kill these animals and do this
[ __ ] that we're doing to these animals
that is affecting your consciousness and
one of the things I even said on the
back of meat is for [ __ ] day it says
that I credit removing the violence from
my plate being the catalyst for change
in my entire life something clicked when
I abstained for 30 days from animal
flesh something clicked in my
consciousness man it was it was you know
it was removing that karma from my life
and you know imagine that the pain and
suffering and and I've been saying this
a lot too because now I have a dog and
we rescued this pitbull he's [ __ ]
amazing and you look in this dog's eyes
man just like your beautiful dogs here
there's a soul
there man this consciousness the dog
feels loved the dog feels pain and it's
made me more of a [ __ ] warrior to to
stop and spread the message of what
we're doing to these animals on this
planet and I was just in Europe and we
would be passing the the pig trucks and
this truck and that truck I saw you
posted about oh my god it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] me up man I was like you know you
look in the eyes in the fear there and
you realize that in a few hours that
living entity that being is no longer
gonna be alive because some [ __ ]
wants to eat a [ __ ] sausage we're
going to destroy the life and we have
incarcerated that animal we've created a
holocaust for the animals on this planet
we've actually turned this planet into a
Prabhupada said we've turned this planet
into a hellish planet for the animals
and that's what we're doing and we don't
have a right to do that to these to
these animals and I speak from my own
experience you could call it hippie
[ __ ] or whatever the [ __ ] you want
but I'm telling you right now some of
the baddest toughest [ __ ] that
I've ever [ __ ] come in contact in my
life when they went and they abstain
from the animal [ __ ] the light switch
came on in st. hippie [ __ ] this is real
[ __ ] that we're talking the himsa is
real [ __ ] and when you come from a life
of violence and seeing people's throats
get cut in front [ __ ] shot and
murdered in front of you in prison and
all this [ __ ] that myself and these guys
have personally witnessed saying Quentin
and [ __ ] they've been in the worst
prisons man you know Pelican Bay and
[ __ ] like just every fucked-up place
Chino everyplace you could possibly
imagine that is Hell on Earth and then
you're telling these dudes look man
remove the violence from your life
completely you're in this program but
you're still ingesting violence and
you're surrounding yourself by violence
because you're responsible because
you're eating that you're part of the
karmic chain of that animal
and that animal improv I said anyone who
grows the animal anyone who transports
the animal anyone who kills the animal
anyone who cooks the animal and anyone
who eats the animal gets the Karma and
from my own personal experience I know
that to be the truth like I don't want
to have a hand in that
so at the same time you know it's worth
it's worth mentioning or recognizing
that that you know in hims this this
idea this this ideal of avoiding harm is
is just that it is an ideal like none of
us are karma free no you know I know
that you don't look at yourself is any
better than anybody else has gone on a
podium or anything like that and just by
virtue of us existing we're contributing
on a karmic level to you know two
problems no matter what you're ingesting
right so it's really about like how can
I reduce that yeah its reducing just
like you're reducing your your your your
carbon footprint you want to reduce your
karmic footprint you know you can't stop
the killing there's bacteria in your
stomach that you're eating food that's
killing the bad bacteria so you know
it's that's the material world one
living entity is food for the next is
always gonna fight whatever is being
born it's gonna it's gonna you know
you're born you grow you produce some
offspring you dwindle and you die that's
that's the material world in a nutshell
that's what's happening but where you
what you do between birth and death
that's up to you to take the proper
action and say hey man you know I'm
gonna live this life that's gonna be
more conscious and aware of what I'm
doing and not just be this blind
consumer you know consuming these
products and sucking up this [ __ ] that's
easing out of the [ __ ] TV with this
politics and that's why I said yeah it's
become the divided States of America and
that's what these people are doing now
it's like they know what the [ __ ] time
it was to be electing this guy Trump in
all this
divisive nough stats gone that's going
on in this case it's sick and those
labels in those walls exist even with
people's diets and people's religions
and people's everything that's why it
says that one Swami said about Prabha
that he built a house that the whole
world could live in peacefully because
what are the principles tell some other
[ __ ] moved into it
yeah and [ __ ] it up yeah some
squatters had to get kicked
yeah yeah but let's uh let's talk about
service a little bit like you're
somebody I mean you're really an
inspiration to me for the the level you
know the service aspect of your life is
really the priority of everything you do
right and that that really like I've
watched you over the years and time and
time again I've seen you as somebody
who's had opportunities to kind of
capitalize on this and monopolize on
this like get a better apartment or kind
of just do what we do as humans as
humans with aspirations to you know live
better lives and consistently I see you
make choices where you walk away from
those things in order to ensure that
you're your priority of being of service
is always first inform us like in tact
whether that's the soup kitchens that
you do or you know whatever it is bro
like this documentary like everything
that you do is about that is about
helping people and and I'm interested in
like your perspective on on how like
what I know is that people that that
live in that place which is a place I
aspire to live in more are are the
people that ultimately not only have the
biggest impact on the world in a
positive way why shouldn't say always
but I see the impact of that but they're
also the most Purpose Driven fulfilled
and the happiest I have to say
you know that's true I mean my happiness
has not derived from getting the next
thing or you know and I wrote about this
in his book I said that somewhere along
the line I realized that having a lot of
[ __ ] ain't what brings you happiness
because I never had nothing and I've
given what I didn't make when I had it I
gave it away and my mom she couldn't
understand when I took a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars that I had saved
up and opened up the yoga center and
then maintained it for ten years you
know spending probably close to half a
mil I Q cousin aunt like it wasn't free
right yeah I didn't get anything as a
matter of fact I did the construction in
the place to on at 93 st. marks and then
I just turned over the key and I was
kind of like the protector of the place
making sure nobody came there and [ __ ]
with it or did anything what's known as
like the temple commander I just made
sure nobody [ __ ] around and did
anything stupid and when people came in
there and misbehaved they got a warning
and then the next time it's like alright
[ __ ] but the point is my mother
was like you could have had a house you
could had and I'm like ma this is what I
want you to do I want you to come to the
Sunday feast and I want you to meet the
people that this place is helping and
the family that we've developed with the
community and all these beautiful people
that had gotten off drugs and and and
overcome horrible [ __ ] by doing what I
did with the bhakti-yoga and this is the
place that they're they're learning it
and they're healing so she came to the
Sunday feast and she's like now I
understand she was like this is the most
[ __ ] beautiful thing that these
people you know are changing their lives
you're helping so many people and I'm
like you know there's a lot of people
living in big mansions man and they're
miserable people and they have no love
and
and the Friends of a rockier there's a
lot of them around here and we passed
some places but you know everyone's
sponging off them and they don't know
who to trust the day after my money it's
like if you're my friend I know you're
my friend cuz you're my friend I ain't
got [ __ ] to give you only you think I
could give you is my time and and my
service and try to help you
you're not my friend cuz you could get
something from me materialistically
that's I don't have that to offer and
you know I you know when it comes it
comes I'm not attached to it either way
the bhagavad-gita says you have the
right to the work you don't have the
right to the results of the work that's
not what you're supposed to concentrate
and meditate on but the happiness of the
service that I've done over over since I
learned about it in 81 and started my
journey I wouldn't trade it for the
[ __ ] world if you said to me yo you
can go back and I'm gonna give you
[ __ ] ten million dollars I wouldn't
take it and that's the God's honest
truth I've turned down TV shows and all
kinds of [ __ ] cuz it's not along the
lines of my core values and what what I
see as important so my happiness is not
derived from you know it's not from
service that in what's interesting is
that that that's very punk rock it is
it's not selling out yeah you're not
supposed to sell out that's the ethics
of punk rock but too many [ __ ]
did sell out everybody could talk to
talk but guess what what is maquis a
true characters revealed under pressure
and when that money came dangling in
front of people's faces you saw a lot of
people change and take off one uniform
and put on another this ain't a
[ __ ] uniform for me that's why
even back in the day I said this ain't
about fashion and clothes and how you
look some of the most punk rock
[ __ ] I ever met don't look like
a punk rocker punk rock is a spirit man
it's a [ __ ] consciousness it's like
[ __ ] the man it's about us the people
and how do we help people you know you
can't just and that's one of the things
I always said about
Rokk I'm like it ain't enough to just
[ __ ] complain about something and
[ __ ] about it
how do we fix it and that's where that's
not punk rock but punk rock is more like
anarchy like blow it up right they're
not big on solution yeah well that was
what I was finding but then I was seeing
people like the Bad Brains and crass who
started organic plant based communities
and [ __ ] this and that and like you
started hearing about other people in
Chrissie Hynde what's she into and she's
into Vedic stuff and and all these
different people and even the guy from
the dam captain sensible was vegan and
like all it is he's you saw an
underlying spirituality in the in the
punk rock movement and a lot of people
in the movement like I said when I was
getting down with this [ __ ] in 81 82 it
wasn't too many aware of conscious punk
rockers a lot of them are [ __ ] laughs
that I stopped eating meat and that I
would go to the Krishna temple and
meditate and go do yoga or what do you I
mean they would say to my face well
there's the straightedge you know move
now within later that was later right
that came later and that was part of the
whole kind of judgmental they didn't
they didn't come at people on the same
level they came at people thinking they
were superior to everybody else and
that's why everybody hated that [ __ ]
movement and that's why everybody hated
the [ __ ] vegan movement because they
didn't come at a compassion a lot of
people just were like I have this
knowledge that makes me superior to you
I'm even gonna [ __ ] you know talk down
to you like I'm better than you
and I think that's changed a lot now
because more and more conscious people
are getting into this for the right
reasons like I said I see it as a
positive thing and a lot of those
people's voices got silenced as a matter
of fact I've seen a lot of them go back
to eating meat and and and and leaving
punk rock and straightedge and going
back to do drugs and all kinds of [ __ ]
so when you get into something for the
wrong reasons that's not going to
sustain your values and your desire will
always be tested in life whatever the
[ __ ] you pick up in this
to attach yourself to that's why I don't
put any of them labels on myself I know
what my ultimate service is it's
bhakti-yoga
well that sanctimony doesn't help
anybody yeah you know and I think when
somebody's coming from that perspective
or you can feel that vibe where they're
there they're rolling up with a level of
you know superiority around whatever
idea it is whether it's veganism or or
whatnot
that's not attractive and it doesn't
work and usually it's a reflection of
the pain that that person is carrying
around or their their their need to
adhere to a certain ideology or belong
to a particular tribe in order to feel
safe and okay in the world so it really
speaks more about that person than
anybody else but ultimately it's not in
service to you know greater humanity
because it's preventing people from
accessing ideas that might be helpful to
them and and what I love about you is is
is this is this devotion to transcending
the label and rolling up on people from
a from a perspective of compassion and
non judgment and you know that's it
that's a higher that's an elevated
perspective that's you know how I'm what
I'm trying that's how I you know aspire
to communicate with people you do and
ultimately you know that that that is
giving you the better chance of being
able to connect with another human being
in a very real way and ultimately that's
the only way you're ever going to be
able to communicate a message that will
be potentially helpful to them in a real
way yeah absolutely I mean you know even
in this place where I'm at with these
guys like society looks down on them and
have treated them in this program you
know society looks down on them as trash
and if you saw 13th the documentary they
replaced the word slave with criminal
she is the whole thing is still that
slave mentality
that they can label them as criminal and
it's like okay now we don't have to give
a [ __ ] about these people they're
criminals depersonalization oh yeah it's
deep that that's exactly what it is it's
like don't even treat them as humans
they're [ __ ] criminals and they're
trying to do away with this whole thing
too now you saw that about I think it's
called the block Bach double block the
box campaign or whatever different no
it's to remove off the job applications
that they've been convicted of a crime
it's happening in California there's a
big push for that right now and you
don't have to disclose that your yeah
and I think that that's true because you
know if you paid your debt to society
and you did the time why should you
continuously be punished these guys
can't even get jobs not that they should
at McDonald's just to show you or a
[ __ ] janitor or whatever it's like
somebody has to give a [ __ ] enough about
human beings to say hey man I'm willing
to take a risk on you and let you come
and you know work at my establishment
and you know I have to say that you know
I give props to tal Ronan because
Crossroads you know he'd never judges
anybody man whether they did a crime or
whatever he treats them like family it
[ __ ] you know it's it's it's like
there's so much love going on in that
restaurant and I think above the food
being amazing I think it's really
because of the love that exists when you
go in that kitchen man these guys are
like they [ __ ] love tile and and just
knowing that dude he's so real and
genuine and he really means it and and
and gave guys a second chance and III
think seeing the humanity in people man
even though we you know they might have
made [ __ ] pretty bad mistakes but
anybody can change and that's the whole
thing you know anybody can and the
system needs to change you you uh you
listen to my episode with with John
McAvoy [ __ ] was [ __ ] and what he's
doing now with that
has has holy [ __ ] it started with I mean
there was a lot of internal drive on his
part but it was sparked by a prison
guard who took an interest in him when
he didn't have to
there you go on his days off and come in
and work with him with the rowing and
right and showed an interest like yo
this guy gives a [ __ ] about me and he's
not trying to get anything from me
he's [ __ ] he honestly cares he sees
something these people have been made to
have no vet they don't value themselves
so when somebody else comes in and says
hey man you have value man like it just
said at first you have to overcome the
the guarded skeptic is skepticism
because that person's gonna be like
what's your angle like no one's ever
Lisa up on me like that so it's like hey
man where are you coming oh my god it's
just a ticking time bomb until you're
gonna drop on me whatever it is you're
trying to get out yeah right so you have
to earn that trust over time like it
can't just happen with one person being
nice one day like you have to be
committed to overcoming that hurdle in
order to engender the trust in that
individual that will ultimately catalyze
that change and that requires that's it
that's a big ask that's a big investment
it has to be socially somebody do that
like that's an amazing thing well it has
to be selfless too you know it has to
it's selfless service it's you know what
it says even in the Vedic teachings is
the devotional service to others has to
be unmotivated and uninterrupted and
that means unmotivated by you know
materials things other than the person's
own growth and uninterrupted if you're
not seeing the result imagine you're
trying to do something and I've tried
that listen I tried to help a lot of
people these three kids that most of
them doesn't wake up they raped and
murdered a woman you know and it's like
it has to be on you know unmotivated and
uninterrupted meaning like sometimes
you're not always going to get the
result right away but you have to just
keep endeavoring and endeavoring and you
know the material conditioning is so
heavy in this material world that you
know we've been doing [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
for this lifetime past lifetimes there's
a there's a lot of conditioning that
that's there and everybody's working out
their karma but you know I'm even seeing
it with these guys now they're trusting
when we first get in there they were all
like yeah what's the small [ __ ] angle
what [ __ ] yo you could see the
skepticism now they're like they're like
yo J you like they calling me and
they're [ __ ] like yo they see I'm not
trying to get nothing from them I'm
trying to give you know this move this
whole process 30 to life is about giving
and the story of John McAfee man and
what he's doing now because now I follow
him on social media and he's going he's
getting standing ovations full right
when he gives these talks yeah he went
and spoke at the House of Commons right
so at the podcast and that video like
went crazy viral and I got up the
morning of Ironman Hamburg because I was
like I got how's he doing right because
that was his big race and as you know
they had to cancel the swim on that
because of the ecology freaking you had
the algae from the runoff and whatever
[ __ ] is going on there so there was
it was gonna be this duathlon and I log
in to the Ironman website wanting to see
how he's progressing and he hadn't even
started yet and I was like what what's
going on something's wrong so i DM him
and he said yeah there was a [ __ ] his
parole officer had the wrong dates for
the Ironman and he couldn't go to the
race because they screwed up some
paperwork over it so he couldn't travel
because he can't travel when a whole
bunch of [ __ ] I'm finding that with
this program now John Paul's trying to
get him skydiving and the parole
officers have not it's out of their zone
where they can travel to it was there
like you know wearing a [ __ ] monitors
and [ __ ] so it's like it's a whole thing
you know to get the clearance from the
parole officers you know it's tough yeah
so he trains for this race this is his
big race for the year and then like I
don't know when he found out how many
days in advance but then it's like yes
are you can
do that mm-hmm you know so he's got
another racy signing up to do but like
the the bigger point being like look
what that guy is done with his life mate
and that is that is you know he that he
wasn't walking around with PM a from day
one like that guy had to evolve into a
perspective where now he can be this
beacon of light right and it's so
powerful because not only is that story
just beyond belief like it's just an
insane like it's so cinematic whereas a
movie uh when he was telling you're like
there's no way right and that gives him
the gravitas like the weight the power
right be able to speak to these issues
and the fact that he is committed to
prison reform you know that's his
version of your service and when you see
Paul de Gelder committing his life to
shark preservation and the preservation
of the oceans when it it's the ocean you
know it is the shark planet you know
yeah and it's the shark he's protecting
that wishing changed his life exactly
and I saw him say I don't know that I
would want my limbs back you know I
think it was on your podcast that he
said that if somebody said you can have
your leg and your arm back I wouldn't
take it I mean somebody and you know
that he means it so the question for you
is why like why do you do all this first
of all I have to say that it's a degree
of selfishness in that it's how good it
makes me feel to help other people
genuinely feel how good it is and going
out on the food line and feeding people
plant-based meals and having these
conversations with people and
and helping people in everyday writing
letters to people and getting people I
mean every day I get 20 to 30 [ __ ]
emails on social media or my I'm gonna
read you one right now
I don't want to interrupt you but I'm
gonna read you an email that came in
that you got but it also was sent to me
can I do this yeah all right I'm not
gonna say the person's name but it goes
like this
hey rich I also sent this to John Joseph
couldn't find your direct email blah
blah blah I want to reach out personally
because of the impact you and John have
had on on me over the last few years
here's the email in its entirety rich
and John I just wanted to say thank you
for the impact you've had on my life
over the last few years I have
ulcerative colitis and struggle for the
better part of ten years with flare-ups
and hospitalizations I was lucky to
avoid surgery but that didn't mean I had
a good quality of life eventually I went
on a drug that cost twenty five thousand
dollars a year it's known to cause
cancer in some patients but to me it
outweighed the higher risk of colon
cancer due to chronic inflammation
during this time about three years ago I
was also trying to make positive changes
in my life to try to get off this
cancer-causing drug while I was thankful
for the effects of form pharmaceutical
intervention intervention played on my
symptoms I was also aware that blah blah
blah Canada had the highest IBD rates
he's like Japan and China had very few
duh-de-duh I listened to audiobooks and
podcasts frequently I was listening to
finding Ultron audible I interjected it
with an episode where Ben Hobbs
interviewed John Joseph it led me to
JJ's interview with rich the rest of the
podcast didn't take long before I was
convinced that a plant-based diet was my
only option I struggled at first but
eventually came around and after three
or four months I was nearly 100%
plant-based my goal was just to increase
fiber intake ba-ba-ba-ba-ba basically it
cured his ulcerative colitis essentially
he his doctor said he'd never seen such
a wild turnaround and that the only
cases where he saw this kind of healing
were mild cases with very few flare-ups
he goes on and on and on and he refuses
to say he's cured it's still too early
the disease is complicated but he's
basically found freedom you know and
it's
your message dude and I know you get
emails and I'm not reading this to like
butter you up or to be
self-congratulatory like it's just it's
powerful dude and I will echo your
sentiments othing better than getting an
email like that no no if somebody that
you're helping somebody in a very real
way and it's just it's just words on a
computer screen but you know not for
that dude no yes that's that's [ __ ]
years of pain and suffering that's in
that email and you know the thing that
was told to me is like how do when I
asked my teachers how do I would pay you
they just said teach the next person in
line pay it forward and that's that's
really what it's all about and when I
say that in a selfish way I mean that
the joy that's derived from helping
people it's it's incredible and it's not
that I'm trying to have this Jesus
complex or any of the [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] like that
because I try to always turn it back on
them and I say yo I put the information
out there but you sir ma'am you did the
work you get the kudos not me all I did
was just like this guy he did the work
he changed his life you know how and I
wrote about you in my new book and I was
like do you know what it [ __ ] took
for you to kick alcohol and do all the
stuff that you did the intestinal
fortitude that that took to change your
diet and do for and do you know the
alters you've done and do the epic five
you know and you know constantly being
put on the pressure you know is the
revelation of true character who the
[ __ ] you really are and you know to me
it's like to get asked you know why it's
the one answer that I would give is is
is like we have a debt we our lives was
saved your life was safe people say
people helped you even Julie and I read
all this stuff and so many people say we
have a debt how the [ __ ] do we had a
how do we repay the fact that because I
think what's risen and get [ __ ]
killed on the streets for being a drug
addict and robbing crazy [ __ ]
like how do I repay that and the only
way is to constantly every day I wake up
I touch my head to the floor and I say
my mantras and I've done that for the
last since I ever heard about it in in
81 37 years even in my crack period in
pill period I wake up and I touch my
head to the floor
the moan Vishnu budaya Christmas dial
delay I say my mantras and I give thanks
for another day on earth and now because
of all the work I've done on myself I
say you know send me someone to help
today I'm looking for that you know to
be like let me find somebody that's and
I get letters about like dude I
literally had the [ __ ] gun in my
mouth and like I got one letter like
that about the lyrics and the cro-mags
that this song I wrote malfunction and
how like you know people's lives have
just been helped that's the greatest you
know feeling in the world that you
helped somebody who was suffering
because like we're living in a world
where it's like people are acting like
it's not cool to be compassionate and
care about someone it's this it's
because look at this [ __ ] that's going
on with this whole [ __ ] presidency
and everything it's like [ __ ] you
separating mothers from their children
and putting them in [ __ ] camps and
all this crazy [ __ ] it's like [ __ ] you I
am my political beliefs I don't care if
you're suffering all this [ __ ] that's
going on we just have to pull back from
that and say hey man this is a living
being man this is a human being with
feelings and emotion and you know pin
you know has the ability to do amazing
things with their life like I want to
fan that spark man I don't want to throw
water on it I want to help
whatever good look for the good the
center of good in people that's what you
have to look for and try to fan that
spark man how can we make compassion
cool you know how can we make caring
cool you know we're in this age of irony
irony and and and you know flippant
skepticism and anger and and and and
fear and and and a zero-sum attitude
about the world if you get this then I
don't get mine and [ __ ] you I think it
comes down to the core value system
again because there's prisons filled
with [ __ ] that thought that way
and it's like I'm gonna get mine no
matter what or you get people in the
material world I'm gonna exploit
everybody and get mine no matter what I
don't care who the [ __ ] they they step
on but there has to be a spiritual
awakening and spiritualities is becoming
cool it's it's not and I'm not talking
about the people who go to yoga class
and stand on their [ __ ] head and then
they go eat [ __ ] steak tartare and
[ __ ] and do all this other crazy [ __ ]
and [ __ ] banging you know that's not
yoga that's gymnastics there's a real
spirituality too intense work on oneself
and I think there's a lot more people
that can smell the lie now in the
hypocrisy that exists everywhere and
they're looking outside of that whole
system of just [ __ ] and the lies
it's we're becoming oversaturated with
[ __ ] it's being just pumped at us
constantly on billboards and [ __ ] but
seeing all these people even you know
they just get above people and exploit
the [ __ ] out of them all over the world
and and nobody's caring and it's like I
just think like the way the way to heal
all of that is is is to let people find
it for themselves but point them in the
direction so that they feel like they
made the journey because ultimately they
are like I just point people in the
direction of the knowledge I say bro go
down this [ __ ] rabbit hole and do
some other [ __ ] research and then I
get and I tell them read this book that
book go look at his documentary check
this out see what this is about and then
they do it and they come back
they like y'all and I just got like five
messages today I've been playing bass
for a month man I feel [ __ ] great I
started doing yoga like I stopped
drinking like y'all even me and my wife
the whole our relationships better you
know and and and a lot of other things
come into play too with helping people
because um my life is the result of like
crazy [ __ ] that my father subjected my
mother to so it's like a lot of these
people have kids and if they don't fix
their damaged cell the saturating what's
gonna you're perpetuating the circle the
the cycle of abuse and incarceration and
everything and the similar the common
denominator of a lot of these guys is
broken families man how do we tighten up
the family look at the beautiful things
that go on in your house with your kids
and how you and Julie love each other
and are nurturing to your kids and
setting the proper example you guys set
the example and that's why I keep saying
examples better than precept you could
talk all the [ __ ] you want about yoga
and this and that [ __ ] don't
care about that because there's a lot of
mouthpieces out there that just talk
[ __ ] talk [ __ ] and then when you really
pull back that mask and you see what the
[ __ ] is behind that that's an ugly ass
person and I don't mean that on a
physical I mean that inside that person
is nothing that anyone's attracted to
because it's it's all they're developing
the bad qualities it's it's instead of
the you know The Four Agreements which
they practice the four disagreements as
so to speak so you know look at you know
that that family and I think the family
makeup has changed a lot too and that's
why I'm like oh if two women or two men
want to adopt a kid and then parents
[ __ ] up and they cause that [ __ ]
kid so much pain so what if those people
want to love that person why the [ __ ]
should they not be allowed to adopt kids
like they're gonna give that kid a
nurturing home
not looking to do you know and that's
the thing that these homophobic people
and all these people they're like oh
yeah who knows what they want to do with
it's like that's your twisted [ __ ]
brain you are projecting well who was it
that said the the only source of self
the when we criticize others that's the
real true source of SEL of what your
projection it's a window in your into
your yeah I don't know who originally
but it's like you know I think the
family structure is a very important
thing and super important I want to talk
about I want to ask one question you
know before we jump ahead to that cuz I
had a question about John McAvoy did you
get into like plant-based diet with him
and all no I didn't know it wasn't about
that with him yeah you know I just I
wanted to share his story which is so
powerful right like I that would have
been a destroy he's not you know he's
not vegan he's on a plant-based alright
you know I want to have that
conversation with him later but they
felt that would not have been
appropriate yeah you know but that's
what I love about you and you have
people on your podcasts that have
amazing stories of triumph and and stuff
like that and you put them on there
regardless if they're plant-based or not
it's the story that's inspiring your
podcast is inspiring dude I gotta tell
you I sat down town and the last couple
days [ __ ] I was eating outside this
vegan spot and and I had literally five
people come up to me and were like y'all
man
you know heard you on a rich whole
podcast man I [ __ ] love rich low like
I'm I'm doing triathlon now because of
that [ __ ] and like like just the amount
of people that you have inspired through
your podcasts and these inspiring people
that come on and doing amazing things I
mean you know well I appreciate that
I mean look man you know you you you
bring the fire you bring the heat every
time you're here so people are
connecting with you I just I'm like a
cipher like I get to be the conduit so
that you can share your truth more
broadly and it's a privilege and an
honor
to be able to to to have the platform to
be able to do this and I think to your
point about kind of bifurcating these
conversations it's like yeah tons of
plant-based vegan people on but like
like you said like I'm more than like
I'm more than that and just because
somebody isn't on a plant-based diet
does that then exempt them from having
an inspirational story of course not
that's ridiculous the dog leggings yes I
don't look at what this guy overcame
you're gonna then judge him because he
doesn't eat the way that you eat like to
me that doesn't make sense it doesn't
you know doesn't so so he's not capable
of providing you with some insight and
some wisdom that can be helpful to you I
think if you're coming from that
perspective then and and it you know I
think that's if you're coming from that
perspective you're robbing yourself of
an opportunity to low and to grow and
learn every individual that you come
across has something that you can learn
from absolutely you're like in recovery
there's that thing like hey man you
learn as much from the people that go
out as the people that stay in everybody
carries the message one way or the other
you know I mean and it's up to you to be
able to have the insight to figure out
okay what is what can I gain from that
person's experience that can be helpful
for me and there isn't a human being
walking on planet Earth that you can't
learn from and if you're coming from a
holier-than-thou perspective and think
well that guy doesn't see the way the
world the way that I do so you know
screw him or I can't learn from him then
you're that you're the you're the one
who's losing out you're missing out
absolutely absolutely so I want to talk
about the new book but before we do that
you mentioned a couple minutes ago like
you meet these people you try to be of
service and helpful to them and you
recommend you're like what read this
book you know watch this dot like what
is it so if you're if you had to like
write down here's the list of things
that are your most recommended books or
movies what's on that list
it's podcasts - and
first and foremost I I tell them the
documentaries for their diet which is
obviously forks over knives what the
health I tell them to check out
Earthlings for the compassion and Cal
spirit see for the environment so you
know those are really the top films that
I'll tell them to check out and books
there's even this one I quote all the
time prophet one of the first books I
read bhagavad-gita as it is and the
science of self-realization that was the
book actually I even said in evolution
of a cro-magnon my memoir that you know
if you want I'll send you this book and
I've sent out thousands of copies of the
book which you know I paid for myself
bought the book shipped it paid for
everything
so in Napoleon Hill books to Napoleon
Hill absolutely they you know there's
you know for self-help and and you know
he wrote some great books and even like
the i-ching
you know and a man I've read so many you
know even you know you can even check
out the Krishnamurti books I love that
ROM das book be here now it's just great
inspirational quotes I tell you a story
about that yeah so ROM das is not the
guy who said be here now be here now was
uttered by bhagavan das so ram das
arrives in india he's searching for his
guru he's convinced he's gonna find his
guru he's walking all over the place
meeting with everyone it's like not
working out and richard alpert you know
harvard professor is his real name
yeah and he's and he's sort of dismayed
and thinking well maybe this isn't where
i'm supposed to be he's starting to
question why he went to india in the
first place and he's about to like pack
his bags and come back home and he runs
into this dude who's like
6:7 young handsome guy with the long
hair and the the hole he's American but
he's got like all the garb on right he's
got the sandalwood on his forehead and
he's barefoot and it's like 1968 or
whatever it is and and the guy's like
come on I'm gonna take you to this guru
and they're walking and they're walking
and like Richard Albert aka ROM das it's
like when are we gonna get there man
when it this this is far like how long
we walking you know you just kept like
he was so impatient like he wasn't
present and the experience of this
adventure
and finally bhagavad turned around to
him and said like be here now that
becomes the name of the book
ultimately they end up at the feet of
neem karoli baba who becomes you know
who names Rahm Dharam das wanna ruin all
that whole thing but Bhagavan have you
ever met Bhagavan no because he would do
kirtan at jeevanmukti
in New York spends a lot of time in
upstate New York etc but Bhagavan Mary
my friend Mary Julie and I there's a
portrait of him in the other you know
yeah Wow yeah that's cool I want to see
that and he did and he's an amazing
musician and he did a kirtan album that
was produced by one of the Beastie Boys
I think Mike D I'm not sure I can't
remember okay
maybe uh I think it always know was well
yeah uh-huh
MCA well who's the one who's the biggest
yogi that's Mike T I think it was Mike D
who lives out in Malibu yeah yeah that's
Mike D yeah that's amazing way yeah yeah
so he was he's a character cuz he's he's
not like a guru type guy like you can
talk to him like a normal he's very
right you know like he's actually pretty
funny dude wow that's I'll tell you more
stories about that later but anyway all
right dude let's talk about what William
a come on media we didn't finish with
that we got to the books in the films
and our so you know but be here now is
it amazing yeah there's a lot of truth
in there
and then you know the Krishnamurti
teachings but mainly I try to just I
really tell people you know to pop up
books and then podcast and yeah I have
to say not just cuz you sitting here
I say look man go on a rich roll podcast
and look at the guests and go to that
there's lessons to be learned in what
was the I just sent somebody because
they were a swimmer and they were gonna
do this big swim what was the woman's
name member lee kimberly she like broke
a foot and yeah she has she's got a
disease right now Wow
yeah I can't remember the name of it
right now but she's uh she's incredible
yeah you know shakashaka quarters and
like forget and so there's always some
swims you know all the different people
that you had on your podcast it's like
there's stories there for everybody I
think it's a very powerful medium
podcast help people so that's really
what I tell people in a nutshell this
just do the research right and people
you know want to feel like they
discovered it that you you just point
them in the right direction and then let
them you know and attach it you got to
detach from your expectations or your
exactement as to whether anybody's gonna
do it and that's that's a painful lesson
that you learn in in in recovery when
you're trying to help people get sober
because you carry the message and you
know nine times out of ten it doesn't it
doesn't stick you know but you just keep
doing it keep doing right you stay out
of the results you know exactly you just
keep that's exactly what it is man it's
like I tried to help my nephew he's
incarcerated again and then there's
another kid today and I talk about this
in the book that he they all made fun of
this kid Matt cuz he was a nice kid in a
sweet kid and they called him make all
them all kinds of [ __ ] up names and
made fun of him Matt got an apartment he
graduated college he has a wife he has a
cake
he [ __ ] has a job and we're all these
other dudes that made fun of him it's
not cool to be kind right but they're
all [ __ ] locked up including my
nephew who made fun of them because he
had a little bit of a learning
disability Matt but he worked so [ __ ]
hard to cure himself of that and
graduate college and I'm so proud and he
calls me uncle John it's funny because
he's like this six-foot-seven you know
black man now but I knew him as a
teenager and you know people like
they're like Uncle John thank you know
this [ __ ] short white [ __ ]
yeah it's pretty funny you know but I
love the kid man he comes he comes to
every event that I do he came to the
last the book thing when we did the
media so [ __ ] know the one downtown
at the [ __ ] no the one in New York
when we did it at what I was when I was
there when your mom was yeah yeah I was
there too and then he came for the
evolution right right for that place in
Brooklyn's not there anymore yeah I know
it closed then it's crazy all right dude
PMA effect you got this new book coming
out the PMA effect are you showing it
there yeah like do you have any printed
copies you could have had one sitting
right here not because we just I don't
need it I read it I really know I read
it already
thank you for her you always [ __ ] me up
man cuz you're so eloquent and then I
got a it's like you're like the toughest
act to follow but I couldn't write like
you if I if I tried to write like you I
would sound like an idiot yeah you know
them you know I can only write the way
that I write yeah it's it's it's amazing
it that the foreword is amazing thank
you so much man you know for that gift
and it is a gift and but the book is is
really so many people are going through
a lot of [ __ ] right now and I'm like I
just I took all the lessons and I were
and I wrote it you know even the
homeless person you know like you
mentioned had a lesson to teach me in
life everybody had lessons to teach me
so really I just incorporated a lot of
the lessons learned and how I over
certain things in this world by
continuously practicing seeing things
from different perspectives and working
through my [ __ ] and trying to keep a
positive mindset through all the [ __ ]
that I was going through and you know
four years ago a little a little under
four years ago I started like you know
writing stuff down and I talk about that
I have a corkboard I don't know if
you've been in my house I've seen and I
know your writing room yeah
so I pin I just kept painting these
ideas to the to the [ __ ] wall and I'm
like [ __ ] man the PMA things become such
a big thing I mean you know everyone's
getting the tattoos it's on bumper
stickers [ __ ] Napoleon Hill the Bad
Brains even [ __ ] Breaking Bad they
you know they had a pier the guy said oh
he a may in the reference yeah and one
of the things they talked about p.m. a
man you bet add that [ __ ] PMA like I
think it was somebody said it's a wall
and I'm like there's so much to that
there's so much to resiliency and the
methods of pushing through [ __ ] and and
how do I do that and you know and I said
you know even in the intro I'm like you
know this book comes from a place of
humility I'm I'm not fixed I'm still a
work in progress I'm a neophyte on the
path and all I'm trying to do is be the
mailman and say yo this is the stuff
that I've been taught that's helped me
thus far in my life and got me to where
I am and yes I have a lot more work to
do on myself but even this book for me
as a reminder because it's a lot of
knowledge in there and I even quoted him
one of his quotes in the book a prophet
yeah so it's like it was a reminder to
me of work that I still need to do on
myself and I just saw what's never done
it's never done we're all we're all
works in progress man it's and that's
really what you know but it's all about
reaching our ultimate potential in how
do we do that that's why I said how a
positive men
attitude can make you the badass you
were born to be because all of us were
born to do great things with our lives
man and it you know seeing that in every
person and there's also an artist as the
unwanted things in sanskrit that we have
to you know that we have to clear out of
our path it's like boulders on the path
but that's what Prabhas said was with
knowledge those boulders become pebbles
that you can just kick away so that's
where the book was what I love about the
book is it's incredibly accessible and
relatable and there's just no getting
around the fact that that you're this
incredibly powerful steward because of
your life experience right you're
standing in a place where you have the
gravity to speak to this because of
where you came from you know and like if
people want to really hear the whole
backstory of blood-clot like you can
listen to one of our ten podcasts thank
you very first way back or even you know
you've recapped it pretty good on Rogan
the other day like you know conceived in
rape abuse abuse abuse foster - you know
foster homes juvenile detention halls
jails you know drug dealing on the
streets like just just a a road to
nowhere and it's just unbelievable that
you were able to transcend that to live
the life that you're living now so how
do you do that like how does somebody go
from there to here and the fact that you
took the time to extract lessons from
your life and hang them on the
principles that have been transformative
in your journey and then communicate
them in a way that's relatable to people
I think is is is you know keep using
this word is powerful you know it's
powerful and I think it's really going
to help a lot of people man so I commend
you for writing that's why I I wrote it
because I really shouldn't be [ __ ]
sitting across from you right now
no because the statistics and I had
people tell me that [ __ ] that you're
just gonna be another [ __ ] dead
[ __ ] are you're gonna be a
[ __ ] that spends the rest of his
life in prison
you know no you know but I always had
this thing to prove people wrong like
because like and that was my problem
even as a kid was I would never let the
people that hurt me know that they hurt
me I would act like that [ __ ] didn't
matter you're not gonna see me [ __ ]
cry I wouldn't cry in front of them
you're not gonna see me in my pain I'm
gonna keep that even when my girl was
like you know it's [ __ ] unbelievable
you went through all that [ __ ] and it's
like I never knew how much that [ __ ]
really affected you because I'm an
expert at hiding my emotions and and and
not letting and it's still one of the
things I'm trying to work on now and
that's one of the things I talk about in
the book is that you know to confront
things and don't let them Fester and if
if somebody does something that I'm not
happy with or it makes me feel a certain
way I'm gonna get it off my chest I'm
not gonna sit there and hold that poison
in and and let it fester till it until
it blows up on something and yeah well
there's that but then I mean that's an
easy example of like somebody pissed you
off let's address it immediately like or
even if you [ __ ] up to like rectify it
as quickly as possible I have a friend
who calls that like if you're gonna eat
crow like eat it hot you know deal with
it right away
but that's very different from the the
compartmentalization of like the abuse
that you suffered and trying to put on a
happy face and be like well [ __ ] happens
man PMA like I'm just over it and then
you're gonna walk around the Lower East
Side and become friends with every
shopkeeper that shit's still there dude
mmm so confronting that like peeling
back the layers like that's you know
that's a process that took that took me
all the way to like I said it didn't
happen until I started working on the
script and then McKee and that whole
thing that happened with him of him
saying that you know writing about a
character that was abuses to
can cliche of the days about what a
character does as a result of that
that's the story and and then he wrote
in my book that he signed for me he goes
he goes John always write the truth and
you know it was about admitting and
coming clean on what happened to me and
like I said I it took it took so much
work and and you know there's the false
ego that's there like yo you're this
[ __ ] whatever like you know you've
been through all this [ __ ] you're so
[ __ ] iron tough and whatever the [ __ ]
and you know fantasies we have in our
own mind which is all false ego that has
to be stripped away and stand there
naked in the [ __ ] you know like at
the end of the earth and just be like
you know I got to confront this and it
took it took daddy forgive forgive
forgive and forgive yourself well well
you know I mean and I'm not over all of
that forgiveness to because I went back
to that peeped in people's houses and I
it wasn't it I wasn't able to forgive
like even the two dudes that were doing
that [ __ ] to me I was like that's the
first thing I said where are they mmm
yeah I don't know when he went back to
that foster home right I don't know what
I would have done I haven't reached a
point where I could be do you think that
you can get to that place and if you
could I would have we get it all I have
to because it's caught it's causing you
suffering yeah you know that of course
it is because I still have that thing
where like I've learned through the
writing of this book though believe it
or not this has been very therapeutic
for me because like you know it had to
remind me of this stuff so I let a lot
of other [ __ ] go but I know that that's
something that's part of the work that
still needs to be done but there's a
part of me that still I can't remove
myself from the street person and the
[ __ ]
dude who has to tell [ __ ] what
time it is and yeah there's an identity
you're on some level there's an
attachment to that identity right and
there's an ego ego perspective I would
be [ __ ] so it's like when you say the
works never done it's like okay now I
don't look at that right yeah yeah and
it's like that's the one thing
everything else is I've been able to I
forgave my mom I actually forgave my
father like you know I forgave certain
bandmates who did the [ __ ] most grimy
[ __ ] to me who was supposed to be my
friend
you know don't hold no grudges I don't
give a [ __ ] but that's the one thing
that I'm like you know that still kind
of haunts me to this day is ever running
into them because like you know they
took advantage of me and they were
bigger than me and now I'm like you know
it's kind of like that sleepers thing if
you saw that movie we're gonna [ __ ]
like I do die I get so [ __ ] up when I
see that scene and every time that [ __ ]
comes on cuz I'm like you know I
understand I could understand that whole
situation what that dude did to them and
and now they're in the position of
putting fear into that person's you know
Kevin Bacon to again so long since I've
seen that but yeah but as I recall it
like they went to the manta ray we're in
a bar and yeah and he went as he went
downstairs they got out of prison and
all this [ __ ] they would he's tough
Irish hooligans and [ __ ] and then he
goes down to go to the bathroom and he
sees him there and he [ __ ] gets Danny
no the priest that abused all no it was
the it was the warden Kevin Bacon was
one of the guys that worked at the boys
home he was one of the cops that worked
there so then he was eating in the diner
right because all those guys had been in
that boarding house together
yeah and then when he comes back
upstairs he goes and tell his friend
he's like you're not gonna believe who's
look who's [ __ ] sitting over there so
they both went over there and sat across
from him and he's like can I help you I
was like now take a look at me you you
remember me
and he's looking he's like told him I
killed the board at home and he's like
oh yeah I remember you [ __ ] little
pricks and it was just like you know he
had no forgiveness and that's what I
think well I'll lose my [ __ ] if they
don't [ __ ] just straight up and come
out like saying apologizing then it
could get ugly because that's what I'm
looking for and it's not gonna you know
be any sense of forgiveness and you know
but you know that the spiritual jujitsu
is for you to forgive them without an
expectation of any I know that's part of
the work I'm not at that point yet and
it's just you know it's a traumatic
situation that's still gonna require
work on my part you know that's more of
the growth that has to take place and I
know that that's still you know when I
did Ben Hobbs podcast man [ __ ] all of
this [ __ ] my friend dying right before
the race [ __ ] oh and then him my
brother [ __ ] you know in a coma when
I went to do corner the first time and
then like you know thinking of all that
and and what was done to us it's been a
part of my brother's addiction problems
that he can't face and then you know he
just asked his question and I lost my
[ __ ] on the podcast I was like sobbing
for like fifth you know ten minutes and
I couldn't talk you know it was [ __ ]
up but a lot of people heard that and
were like yo including uh Tonio what is
the name crystal that iron the idea iron
mediator Noah Donald Chris or Tim Oh Tim
O'Donnell uh-huh he saw me when I when I
went to the iron man foundation thing
where they showed the thing in New York
he's like brought I was like one of the
most [ __ ] intense moments like but
it's not acting it's it's still raw and
when I see what my brother and I my
brother's been cleaning for 40 days now
oh wow that's nice god it's 30 day coins
pretty good so um you know there's a lot
of people out there who was helped by
the evolution of a cro-magnon and wrote
write me and I think that this is the
next phase in that because we all go to
[ __ ] and I said even if this book
saves one human life how can we put a
value on that then every [ __ ] minute
of everything I spent on that book is
worth it but I think it's gonna help a
lot more people because there's serious
life lessons to be learned there and how
we deal with trauma and how we push past
and how it's not just about success in
making it and [ __ ] becoming like all
that [ __ ] don't matter to me it's
that's not what this book is talking
about is talking about how do we heal
the hurt how do we push past obstacles
in our life how do we push past fear you
know and even talking with you and and
all the other people it's like I asked
those questions all the time because I'm
trying to learn I'm still trying to
learn and I said hey even when I ask you
questions and I wrote about it in a book
like and you know how do we keep growing
and you said face something you fear all
the time do something that challenges
you face your fears
remember one yeah I didn't make that up
by the way no I know but I'm saying you
ya delivered the message just like you
were the mailman you've you delivered
that message and that's what I'm doing
here and the little lightning bolt there
that's enough that's a nod to the Bad
Brains yeah because their first album it
was the lightning bolt coming down right
breaking the capital so it's well what I
what I what I like about that is is that
it's getting at the root of how you
of how you grow and how you evolve into
the best version of yourself you know
most books of this ilk of this genre
it's like how to make a million dollars
how to like network or [ __ ] like that
it's like they're missing the big
picture it's like you can go out and set
a goal and I can tell you how to achieve
that goal but if you want to know if
your goal is the right goal for you
you better start investing in yourself
in the real hard work that is internally
focused in order for you to answer that
for yourself and that's not as sexy
that's that's the the messy kind of
ephemeral you know process that I think
is fundamentally required if you want to
create the best foundation for living
the life that you know that is you know
that is sort of like accessing your best
blueprint for yourself but it's hard to
talk about that stuff and it comes in
all different shapes of forms depending
upon your spiritual perspective and and
you know what you believe and don't
believe but I think you did a really
beautiful job of like exploring that in
a way that that is very inviting and
like I said earlier like accessible to
everybody yeah thank you I mean coming
from you that it means a lot and that's
what I tried to do in this book there's
something for everybody
you know from the hardcore people to the
you know whoever like make it accessible
man and just relate my journey and help
people who might be going through you
know similar stuff I told the guys in
the program every that I'm working in
the documentary dirty to life I said
every one of you guys are getting a copy
of this book and it's amazing like how
smart those guys are they have degrees
and they you they wouldn't be in any
foundation unless they were exemplary
prisoners because that's who gets in
there and they did work they got degrees
and this guy was reading me the stuff
not the musician another guy wants to do
a book and he was reading me this his
level of [ __ ] awareness you don't
understand when you're sitting in his
cell for [ __ ] 20 years and you can't
run from yourself you have to face that
like I had to do the same thing and
everyone does everyone has to face
themselves life is gonna throw something
at you no matter who you are that's how
the button and if you can look at that
like an opportunity well that's how the
book came about everyone was I had
evolution of a cro-magnon and everybody
was patting me on the back and saying
what a great and I thought I had
everything figured out a sob and life
threw me that [ __ ] 80 mile an hour
curve ball and said yo not so fast not
so fast homie
slow down you got a ways to go and
that's how I look at it now I don't try
to ever see it into the journey I'm just
you know okay this set of circumstances
came up today I'm not going to project
ahead or worry about it I'm gonna
[ __ ] I'm alive today like my friend
that died Kevin McQuaid he got you know
he did time in prison he was addict
everything and he told me and I wrote
about it in a book that any day above
ground Johnny that's a good [ __ ] day
and you know if I could I dedicated a
whole thing to him in the book because
like it just shows even with him how
fragile life really is and and the stuff
you know we take for granted and one of
the things I said was imagine someone
who had a near-death experience the next
day how she's gonna look at life she's
gonna watch the birds scrambling on the
sidewalk for crumbs she's gonna smell
the flowers she's gonna notice the
breeze blowing through the leaves you
get a whole different awareness of life
by going through things and I think
that's a lot of the message that the
book takes aways you can take away from
the book is like there's a lot to be
learned in those experiences when we
learn to see it that way like what I
thought was a curse and I
you know now I look at it it's it's it's
all about perspective and vision of how
we see are we gonna play the victim and
I play the victim I'm guilty of it I
played to Victor I had all this [ __ ]
done to me I [ __ ] here's the reason
why I'm nobody would begrudge you
foreplay and yeah of course they'd be
like well he had a rough but [ __ ] that
that wasn't gonna be my story I didn't
let that be my story I wanted I wanted a
different story I wanted a different
path and that's why I keep fighting
every single day and I keep reaching out
to people because that's part of my
service that's Bach bhakti yoga means
devotion to devotion to Krishna devotion
to others helping others it's what the
path is all about it's not about it's
about all of us getting somewhere
I like to look at it as a spiritual
party who wants to party by themselves
man I want to [ __ ] bring all my
friends and everything man and and and
just keep doing big [ __ ] which is
helping somebody else get out of the
[ __ ] you know and that was another
quote they say oh when you hit rock
bottom I said no you could go below the
[ __ ] rocks to the max always a lower
there's always Thank You rock bottom you
could always go [ __ ] lower and by the
way you don't have to hit rock bottom
and everybody's bottom is different we
all have different pain thresholds you
know if you're suffering and that
elevator is going down it doesn't have
to hit the the ground floor yeah you can
step off so to kind of round this out
and and and you know bring it home you
know if someone's listening who's
suffering and they're listening they're
they're hearing your story and they're
like man that guy like I can't believe
how far he's come from where he was to
where he is today but obviously he's
just you know he's a genetic freak or
he's wired differently like I you know I
just can't like I can't get out of my
own way and I'm stuck and I just I hear
what he's saying but like he doesn't
understand my life like how do you
respond to that I'm one word man honesty
and I think that's we have
to be honest with ourselves and I tell
people that all the time
I have not like when people write me all
you did all these races and you've done
all this [ __ ] in the cro-mags I say man
you could do the same [ __ ] thing but
the first thing that it requires is
honesty with ourselves we have to be
charity starts at home we have to be
honest with ourselves enough to say and
I had to do it and I'm speaking from my
I had to say I'm [ __ ] up I'm an addict
a person who has admittedly done grimy
[ __ ] to people that have transgressed
and done [ __ ] against me which I felt
okay now I got the right [ __ ] -
you got what's coming to you so it took
a lot of honesty on my part to be
willing to take that mirror that I'm
holding up to everybody else and look at
everybody else they've flipped that [ __ ]
around and be like I'm the one that
needs to get fixed right how do I hear
the common denominator and all the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] in your life yeah I mean
but that's a big [ __ ] challenge to
accept and I have a chapter called
accept you have to accept the blame mmm
don't keep trying to [ __ ] you know
use events in your life as a scapegoat
for being a [ __ ] up person or you know
everything's everybody's life is
different but we can all attain the same
things if if that honesty is there and
that's one of the 26 qualities of the
devotee is that they're honest you know
it's tough it's that's the hardest thing
man listen man you may look as where I
came from where I'm now but what you
don't see is the 37 [ __ ] years of of
tears and pain and [ __ ] bloodshed and
and and [ __ ] tests that have come
that I've
failed and failed and failed again but
was willing to get the [ __ ] back up and
it's not how many times we got knocked
on our ass it's how many times we're
willing to [ __ ] pick ourselves up and
push [ __ ] through the next gap
between expectation and result and then
the world throws us through another
[ __ ] curveball puts at us at risk
that's story in a nutshell so it comes
down to what do you want your story to
be I didn't want my story to be oh yeah
he was abused and he was abandoned and
he was [ __ ] made to feel like [ __ ]
and it's okay that he's in prison or
[ __ ] dead that was it's
understandable [ __ ] that I didn't want
that to be my story and that's what I'm
trying to tell people with this book
don't let those events that have
happened in your life determine who you
are as a character you can break free of
any of that adversity and it just takes
like you like you said flip the mirror
man look at yourself
stop looking at everybody else and what
they're doing that don't matter what
anybody else does don't matter you know
it's it's about what's going on with us
that's what we have the power to fix is
us we don't have the power to determine
how people are going to treat us or look
about us or talk about us and especially
with social media these days everybody
goes on their talking [ __ ] about other
people it's so toxic coming back to the
Joe Rogan thing it's so toxic and so
poisonous and so disgusting you could
have the best intention in the world and
you still peep see [ __ ] people on
your videos on YouTube thumbs down [ __ ]
this guy [ __ ] [ __ ] him [ __ ] it's such
a weird thing because I can't imagine
even if I had a negative response to
somebody's piece of content to let go
and like you know take let them know
where I'm coming for like like I just
wouldn't do that because your life
really suck that [ __ ] much that you
took all that time to go and [ __ ] go
on that [ __ ] and watch it and then be
with with a poisonous
can comment like that you know The Four
Agreements talks about that not to take
things personal that's their poison
that's their hell and when I saw Don
Miguel speak you know Eva I still read
his book and read those things prettier
that's what I'm writing
yeah I do take [ __ ] personal I'm like
I'm gonna come [ __ ] bash you and
you've yeah I've still got his email no
that's like I'm like that is a plain
[ __ ] month I put you on the guest
list place if you ever want to wind up
my mother [ __ ] like say something
personal because that is your your
Achilles heel dude like that's the
character defect that will like setna ah
and get you didn't do something you're
gonna regret for yes I know we all do
any of them hey you know what all right
man we gotta end this did we record it
sure do two and a half hours awesome I
love you thank you for the forward the
books called the PMA effect the PMA
effect it's for its upper pre or when is
the order link reasons on and on the
orders of the website effect calm pmfs
calm and you know and you got your get
your doing sign books for a minute here
500 of the first copies it's signed and
then
and we got 400 state what's what they
over second the day before my 56th
birthday
right on so how do I not know your
birthday is in October I'm gonna hear
what your 20th and your and Julie's what
true is July oh yeah
so yeah PMA effect PMA for life
we don't know time 30 yeah yeah that's
right so now you say but I said for life
30 or 30 to life 30 I don't know we're
not sure we're coming make sure yeah we
don't we don't know we're gonna be epic
that's all I can say right on dude all
right
all right man let's go get some de
probably doing it peace what are we
doing peace plans take us out with the
mantra thank you for helping everybody
and here's here's my mom here's my
mantra
tayshaun Saturday yuktah Nam but the
budget Tom priti-purvakam dadami
buddhi-yogam tam yena mam will be on
today that's from the bhagavad-gita or
there's nutshell verses of the
bhagavad-gita the essence of the
bhagavad-gita and that means those who
are constantly devoted to the path I
give them the understanding by which
they can come to the supreme in other
words its action take action better
yourself every day don't just keep
talking
zip it there's a chapter in my book
called yo zip it and that's what it's
about take action man and push through
every single day that's what it's about
god bless everybody man yeah I'm not
even gonna say piece implants I just
want that to be the capstone yes sir
brother good talking to you
[Music]